The joe rogan experience podcast is brought to you by the fleshlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net enter in the code name Rogan.
They will give you 15% off of the number one sex toy for men.
Shazamm would talk in discounts.
My friends.
All right.
With that said,
are we should fear is in the motherfucking house.
I could dig.
Quit
talking discounts.
We have to do this music for some reason.
We're married
it [inaudible]
it's like us.
It's not perfect.
It's obnoxious.
He lets you know there's a lot of shit in there.
You would change.
Who made that?
Who made that song got really mentally really quick?
I think Brian made it right,
didn't you make it and actually made it for the old crackle show that we were
doing.
Just do it in Garageband.
It's a mix of the garage band and real instruments affects some amazing you can
do that,
isn't it?
Yeah.
Fuck man.
It's so easy to do stuff to them.
I'll train music.
Do you play any instruments?
No.
That.
I mean I played instruments my whole life.
Like I played bassoon trumpet fucking got a bassoon.
I pay it.
It almost looks like a tube.
I'd like this big mother fucking crazy,
crazy thing deployed.
I know.
Why did you play that?
Because I wanted to play an instrument bad,
but the problem hate pussy as well.
Perfect combination.
It was.
It was like,
I think you had to do it.
You had to pick an instrument growing up and I would,
I liked the trumpet but after awhile I just,
you know what's the hardest one?
I thought the trumpets.
The coolest one.
No Trump.
This.
Trump.
That wasn't that hard though that we just made that distinction and we both
agreed that the bassoon is like fucking stupid instrument is a bassoon.
While the trumpet is like,
yeah,
that's pretty dope.
Like to learn to play the trumpet.
That's cool.
People like you would stand outside a woman's like window with a trust.
Isn't that weird?
That's a weird distinction.
And it's a one week kind of all agree on,
I mean I'm sure there's some bassoon aficionados out there,
right?
But if you had to ask the average person,
you play a bassoon,
they're like,
get the fuck out of here.
But he's like,
yeah,
I played trumpet.
Dams is cool.
Jazz guy who gets laid for a trumpet.
It's here are the best bassoonist trumpets I think of like Denzel Washington and
Mo better blues where I like,
I remember watching it and he's like cleaning his trumpet and Shit.
I was like,
this motherfucker loves that thing.
You know?
He's toning it up and polishing it and girls want to fuck him.
He's like,
I got to practice baby.
I got a practice.
I'm always cracked skin.
It's like you've inspired me and that the trumpet was actually the easiest to
learn really quick.
Not the easiest to master probably,
but I,
that was easy that the secret,
the trumpet is just knowing how to blow it.
It's like using your map going that,
oh,
just learning.
Give me just learn how to actually play something.
It is fucking amazing when you see a dude who really knows how to play.
Though.
I saw dizzy Gillespie when I was a little kid.
Yeah.
When I was living in San Francisco,
they had a,
um,
one of the kind to go into a cool school man,
public school in San Francisco was a seventies.
It was pretty good.
Fast.
Cool.
Yeah.
And uh,
they took us all to see a dizzy Gillespie and he was a crazy one because the,
the,
you're not supposed to go and blow your,
your cheeks out like a fish.
That's not like the proper technique.
But that's how he did it.
And his,
his,
his cheeks were crazy.
They were blocked like a frog.
So like he got,
I guess he is like really powerful lungs and flexible skin and because his
fucking lungs are so powerful because he's been playing trumpet for so long when
he blows it when he wouldn't,
he's dead now.
But when he would,
yeah,
it was crazy.
And I went to see him and I was amazed that this guy can do all this with this
and make all this noise out of this one little instrument just because he knows
it,
you know,
he knows like if he pulls it back just this much,
it'll make that much of a difference.
And if he hits this key and blows a little extra hard,
it'll hit that special note that he wants.
And there's so much variation in the notes,
you know,
it's amazing.
It's an a,
it's an amazing instrument.
The bassoon,
which you'd think it's Sun.
Yuma is growth.
It's the bassoon.
Uh,
when you were a poor kid the day they had ones that you can rent from the
school,
what kind of like a library?
As soon that I had looked like,
it looked like something from the black hole.
Like when those old robots and here something like it was just as beat up,
rusted looking gross thing and like a spit valve was rusted.
Like,
you know,
like the pipe where you opened up the spit and you blow up the spit that that
was just all rusted.
I remember that being so gross.
That was other people spit roads.
Yeah.
Dude,
that's disgusting.
You're stuck with that.
That I used bassoon.
Yeah.
I didn't play that as long as the trumpet.
I play trumpet Pro League for two years or so.
Yeah,
because this is not just a bassoon.
Right.
It's the bassoons and right now if you choose to some dudes,
yeah.
I wouldn't know what I could play.
I could play,
but I,
I wouldn't know anything to play.
You know what I mean?
I could blow it and it would sound like right.
You know,
we could play Beverly.
What's that?
It's when they wake up in the morning.
I used to be able to play.
Right?
Yeah.
Can you still remember it now or no?
No.
You have to mark now it's like,
I can't even remember Spanish.
I took Spanish for four years.
I don't,
I remember old La Multa.
What's motel?
Weed.
Yeah.
See you don't see tall is alto.
Gordo is fat.
I know all the things people would call me.
People were talking shit about you.
That's what you got good at.
It was all body parts,
drugs and just passwords it,
yeah,
that's what everybody does.
Whenever you had a new kid that came from Russia,
like,
dude,
okay,
how do you say bitch?
Yeah,
she's telling me the keys.
Verday Green Roho right.
So Ari,
how was crackers?
You were in Indiana or ended up it.
I want to skeet shooting.
It was totally cool.
What's that?
Where they shoot that?
Well you go yo pull and the this fucking despise
and you shoot it with a real shotgun.
Yeah.
You fucking blow it up twice.
Was that your first time shooting anything?
No,
I've shot stuff before.
When I was in Israel,
we used to go to the,
um,
the frightful range of bunch.
They let it take us out there.
We,
you lie on your stomach there.
I think it was the first time standing up with a,
with a shotgun,
but it blows up.
It's so cool.
You just have to track it and fucking shoot it.
Was it really trippy?
Uh,
no.
I wouldn't describe it as trippy.
It off ain't feeling any aftereffects of the Salvia trip that you had recently,
you know,
I miss that place.
Have you been any afterthoughts?
What have you,
do you have any afterthoughts and now that you've got to stay with you that long
because you had,
it kind of goes away for the listener.
And so he had a pretty much a breakdown on Saudia where you're,
yeah.
You started flailing your legs.
You started,
yeah.
Yeah.
I thought you were a,
I thought you were fucking with me.
Right?
Did you realize looking back now,
do you realize that Sam Tripoli was fucking,
you buy sangs saying shit like I think he's dead.
Oh No,
I looked at it again.
It's just,
I mean,
completely not trusting you.
Nobody has any idea what the fuck you're talking about.
This is the most ridiculous conversation.
Arrows to what happens when let you talk.
You were typing away.
Well,
I was trying to find this thing cause I wanted to ask you about,
there's a story in a,
on CNN today.
Uh,
I know that for those who don't know,
a,
he spent a good deal of his life studying,
uh,
Judaism in the Talmud and you know,
you were explaining your whole situation for people.
That was,
you need to Shiva in Israel for two years.
I was super religious.
It's like a dormitory.
Just spend morning tonight,
uh,
studying,
you can live around Israel too.
You know,
you've seen this,
the country,
but you know,
most of your day,
nine to five,
it's really like eight to fucking 10:00 PM just studying all day long with a
break for lunch,
break for dinner and the services.
Wow.
Yeah,
it was super cool.
Super rewarding.
I was good at,
and then I came home and lost my religion.
That's why I'm a comedian.
And w w you know,
how do you go from that to a is extreme as you are now.
How do you,
how do you make that leap?
What was it,
what was it that made you lose your religion?
I just really thought about it.
I really honestly thought inside do I believe in God and it just wasn't there.
It just wasn't there.
I look for the first time I thought about it and I'm like,
I don't like when I think about,
you know,
you're here,
you don't have this core beliefs and your system,
you know,
summer's warm or whatever it is.
Like you just believe these things.
That's about example,
but it just wasn't in there cause it's not in there.
I don't know if you believe in God or not,
but it's like you either believe or you don't believe.
Especially when it comes to a leap of faith where it's like there's don't
believe or not believe.
I think it's a,
I don't know.
That's my,
my answer to all that shit.
I don't know.
But if it was an argument about anything else except for religion using the same
proofs and he'd be like,
what the fuck you talking about?
There's no performance fucked.
It's no,
it's,
people have a weird desire to think that there's an answer to all of this.
Yeah.
It's a,
it's,
and if you like challenged their,
their,
their thought that they believe in,
they'll get so angry.
They want to fight you and kill you.
Yeah.
But I thought it's supposed to be a leap of,
so you've taken that leap.
What?
So why?
And they're mad if you don't.
Yeah.
Or they're mad.
If you question why they did well,
look,
believe it over the fuck.
You want to believe folks,
we're not,
we're not telling them,
this is why I bonded.
Bring this up to you.
So for some people it helps,
man.
I know people that need religion,
they need God.
They need some,
some idea,
some fucking fiber that there's some path that they can follow something
tangible,
you know,
in the,
in the Bible to them it does it,
I dunno,
whatever,
do whatever the fuck you want.
If that's what you need,
good for you.
Some people need PROZAC.
You know what I'm saying?
I mean it's okay,
no worries.
But here's the key.
Here's the question.
I know you studied ancient Hebrew and you studied,
did you study a lot of the Old Testament?
Oh yeah.
Well,
there's a research group in Canada that support this according to CNN that has
just proved,
and this is this the story that they published,
that the,
uh,
the old testament has been massively mistranslated and falls three years of
research,
which is uncovered that the actual system for translating ancient Hebrew is the
group discovered that each letter is not a letter at all,
but a full word.
And what was believed to be a word is actually a sentence,
like a description which supplies the definition of the word.
I said,
what's a sentence?
A fucking paragraph.
I don't know.
That's a good question.
I don't understand this.
This is one of the reasons why I wanted to bring this up to you because I know
you have a lot of,
a lot of knowledge about this shit about ancient Hebrew each.
So it was what they're saying,
making any sense to you.
What they're saying basically is that sort of get it like they used to think as
far as I know,
um,
my limited understanding,
they used to believe that every letter is also a number.
Yeah.
They still believe that they believe that.
So there's no,
there's no numbers in ancient Hebrew,
right?
It's all letters and numbers are all the same thing.
Yeah.
If you want to show that it was high,
it's just a,
it's a,
it's time for life,
but it's cut.
It's eight and your admins 10 18 so people usually give gifts.
The gift of life is the greatest gift.
So they can get some units at 18 wow.
That's so really bad ass thing.
A language that's like that.
When you think about it,
I will,
I'll language that where it's all like numbers and letters are all intertwined.
Like words have numerical value to them.
Right.
So it's like you can figure shit out that way.
So really any soda translation of that into something else you're losing.
Remember Fuck,
you must be losing almost all of it,
right?
Yeah.
You could still,
if you don't know that language,
you won't get the meeting.
Right.
So you have to translate it.
You have to read just what they're saying.
Make any sense to you.
It makes sense.
But I don't see how that could be.
I mean they know what the,
a lot of those words are.
It makes sense.
The sentences.
Yeah.
They still exist today.
And the same,
the same word.
So waba you know,
so how could they be saying this then?
And that sounds like they're full of shit.
Sounds like not,
don't understand that.
I'd have to really see what the,
what they were talking about.
Exactly what I would think.
It's when some shit gets on CNN that they've done some filtering of it and they
know that they're right.
CNN might not be reporting exactly right or something.
I'm just not sure.
I don't know what that word.
Well and all they have to do is really say a research
group in Canada.
Look,
it's interesting shit.
You know,
even if it's not correct.
It's interesting shit.
And CNN is in the business of getting people to pay attention to interesting
shit.
You know when I go to cnn.com one of the reasons why it goes,
cause every now and then they'll have some weird ass fucking story like this.
We had,
CNN has some good stories,
man.
You know,
you think of CNN has being like to a mainstream website for news and it is,
but there's,
you know,
there's some fucking fascinating shit on there.
Whenever I go to those sites or just go to the Wacky,
wacky section as wacky section,
there's always a wacky section.
You know what?
Let me look for that man arrested himself after too many bananas,
you know?
Yeah.
I used to have a friend that would scour those jokes.
Whenever I write the hackers.
You've ever read packets for like a late night talk show or something?
That's all I look for.
You'll give me a fun.
What story am I going to do about speaker of the house not coming to the puck
and vote today?
I have nothing to say about any of that stuff anymore.
Yeah,
I don't want to talk about it,
but if somebody tried to shoot over a cockroach with a speed boat,
I want to fucking know.
It's so sad to be in that state of mistrust of the government and just not,
and thinking that the system is so completely fuck that you just don't want to
like stop it.
Don't even talk about it to me.
Did you hear what the Democrats did in the floor today?
Shut up.
Shut up world of Warcraft.
There's my new deal.
Talk to me about your wizard.
So it's the same shit when people say like all Republicans are just fucking
idiots.
Midwestern morons.
It's ridiculous.
Just so silly to write that off.
Half the country.
Without that,
they can't,
can't have any point at all.
I agree with Republicans on a lot of shit.
A lot of shit.
A lot of it's just uncontrolled shit.
Separation of tastes,
different tastes.
If everybody would be like old school,
Conservative,
Republican the way it was supposed to be,
it would be smaller business,
smaller or smaller.
Government get the fuck out of our lives.
You live people,
live people alone.
Lead people have purpose,
personal freedom.
But somewhere along the line,
conservative didn't become that.
You know,
being a republican wasn't about.
It was,
it wasn't about limited government.
It's just like all things they become.
What is the most profitable?
What's the best way to do this?
The best way to do this is be completely intertwined with business.
So they're fucking robbing the world and uh,
bribing us all the time.
Well that's how we do it.
Let's just do it that way.
And so that's where it is,
you know,
so republican or Democrat or whatever the fuck it is,
it's all just some shell game that involves people making absurd amounts of
money doing shit that most people wouldn't want them doing,
you know?
Yeah.
So it doesn't matter what offshore drilling sorts of creepy fucking shit that
goes on.
Everybody said they want to get rid of nuclear power plants as is Sweden.
Sweden is powering off there.
She took do they want to be completely off the fucking smart man?
I've got to figure out how to make it like renewal,
not how to use those are newer ones and how to make up like store at the energy.
It's the scariest thing in the world.
The idea that they've created some area that you cannot go to for the next,
who knows how many fucking thousand years.
But that spot,
that one spot will fuck you up a thousand years from now.
If you do and that's fine.
You couldn't eat vegetables for like six months or a year and he said there's
still some barriers.
25 years later you still can't eat because they store it in a certain way.
Are they researching like a thing to stop that or to fix that?
They could spray the hair.
You know what I mean?
I'm sure they are,
but that would be worth some research.
Pretty elemental problem.
I mean,
what you've done is created nuclear fission or fusion.
Which one is it?
Sounds good.
It's one of those vision or fusion.
One of them is a bomb and one or one of them is the sun.
One of them is a nuclear power plant.
Somebody reminded me of this on Twitter,
which ones in [inaudible] when I was joking around,
because I always joke around that like these guys have Japan have made a son in
the middle of the field and now they can't shut it off.
I mean it really is kind of when it's like,
I mean I know it's not exactly the same thing,
but it is something posthumously powerful that you can't even fucking go near
and we created.
Why don't we just use that as where to put all the world's garbage.
Uh,
that's not a bad idea.
Right?
So this story is just going to be a tetris of nasty flyover and just dump it.
Yeah.
That's actually a wonderful idea.
I know.
I like it a lot.
Or prison cells.
No,
that's not,
you're pushing it too.
Did you have and make it a reality show?
Did you watch some more morph?
The latest thing on this,
uh,
large Hadron collider situation is that the large Hadron collider thinking
about,
you know,
talking about shit that you can never get away from.
The large Hadron collider has created a glue on Cork,
uh,
cork glue on plasma and it's many,
many times more dense than a neutron star.
This shit is so dense that if a,
you'd have a sugar cube size of it.
It's like 40 billion pounds.
Okay.
That's what are they going to do with that?
How does it,
yeah.
Hey was around,
they made that on their way to blowing up the fucking world is how they made it.
If I was in that hot,
loud Heidrick or ladder,
I'd figured out a way to do jousting in it.
It's the densest matter available.
It's,
it's,
it's like impossible to us for us even wrap our heads around how dense this shit
is.
That's what's really crazy about that is it's nothing compared to the density of
the original universe according to the Big Bang theory,
the Big Bang theory states that the entire universe was smaller than the head of
a pin.
Somehow or another just one point of infinite density popped open and it just
exploded and created everything.
I mean it's a very controversial theory.
There's a bunch of other ones that other people believe in like brains,
like membranes,
theories that there's like every universe is like a membrane.
Sometimes they collide with each other and it's a never ending cycle and then
then there's another,
this is a bunch of different theories of constant expansion and contraction.
That's what the universe does incidentally,
just constantly expands and contracts forever.
That's a few sessions to me.
When I was in sixth grade,
that's where I was super into that.
When I found out the university and closed and they're
just sort of stopped.
He just got tired.
I was like,
I know there's a lot of shit on her so
it doesn't affect you so you don't think about it.
Stop thinking about it.
And I'm obsessed with all that shit.
I'm obsessed with anything.
He liked this,
that I don't think anybody's paying attention to,
especially this cork glue on plasma,
whatever the fuck it is that just,
if you had your choice,
would you have them shut down the large Hadron collider so you could look into
it further?
No,
no.
I think it's natural.
I think what people are doing,
I don't want to be anywhere near it,
but I think what people are doing is a natural thing.
I think that we have a,
uh,
a builtin tendency towards accelerating technology.
We cannot stop.
We can't help ourselves.
We need to know.
We need to know what happens when I do this.
What happens when I do that?
I mean,
look what,
what they're doing there.
They're spending,
there's 10,000 scientists from a hundred different countries.
They have spent billions and billions of dollars and none of what they're doing
is going to help pull oil out of the ocean or fix our food problem or fix are
either trying to do,
are they just trying to see what they're trying to do is create it?
They were trying to create a God particle and crying.
There's the theoretical particle called the Higgs Boson particle and this is a
particle that existed in milliseconds after the big bang and it's this
theoretical particle.
If they can prove its existence it,
it puts a lot of the pieces together of like some sort of a unified theory of
what you know,
what creates the universe,
what the universe is made of,
what sort of,
how to make enough of these particles and put them together.
I don't even know if it's real.
They're trying to make it and on their way to ramping up to make it.
They're making shit like this cork glue on whatever.
It is critical.
Then what do they get?
Well,
if they do,
they also get little black holes.
That's one of the things they get.
This is a,
a real issue that,
uh,
some people are concerned with.
Some scientists say you don't have to worry about it because it's just going to
disappear because they can't,
their mass can't,
uh,
can't exist.
You know,
like there's a there,
they're too small,
they don't have enough gravity and then disappear.
But like fucking how do you know,
man,
nobody's ever made a black hole before shithead.
You're running and you're just out there pressing buttons and,
and I'm not saying they shouldn't be doing it.
I'm not saying they shouldn't be doing it.
Don't get me wrong.
There's people you want to,
you stifling science as if you know science at the,
you have to look at it all objectively,
man sciences and get a free pass.
You have to look at it objectively.
You have to look at what the fuck they're doing.
What are they doing?
You're smashing atoms together and you,
you guys are playing with rocks.
You guys,
you guys are crazy egg head genius.
Motherfuckers know that.
Talk some people into letting you break,
break,
break a fucking hole through this dimension.
That's what you're doing.
This is like,
you know what?
this is like half life.
This is like that God damn video game.
Remember that they blew a hole through another dimension.
Giant crabs came out in Florida.
A picture of you sitting in front of a computer at three 30 in the morning just
going,
I can't,
I'm like,
no,
you cannot miss the crazy
but crazy.
Can you imagine the reviews of the courtyard of the mirror across the street
from the collider?
Cons,
uh,
across the street from this large Heidi on collider.
There's nothing anywhere near Howard Johnson's across the street.
I hop in there complaining free breakfast,
but across street from black hole.
I wonder what it sounds like when Adam's collide at lightspeed.
How about,
it sounds like,
what is that like gay porn?
Yeah.
I wonder if it sounds like anything,
right?
It's probably just,
it
won't go away the rest of our life.
We have to hear that.
And my art,
my thoughts were all of a sudden nobody hears anything for one second.
Right.
The whole world just skips a beat and then once it comes right back.
Yeah.
Well,
I,
you know,
my,
my worry about this is not this necessarily,
it's about what is this spawn,
you know,
the,
the atomic weapons that were first created in 1940 whatever,
you know,
they eventually spawned much more as much smaller,
compact,
much more dangerous topic,
much more powerful atomic weapons.
What is this kind of spawn?
You know,
they're not going to stop at the large Hadron collider a hundred years from now.
They're not going to be sitting around going,
well,
I'll just no need to keep fucking around with naming a search for more
knowledge.
They never even searched for more knowledge and fucking with things,
pressing buttons,
seeing what happens,
making God particle.
You remember the movie black hole?
No.
What was that?
It's where it's a Disney movie.
It's like the first r rated Disney movie.
It was about a black hole going into a black hole.
Whoa.
What happened in 1980 80 to almost give it awesome.
Oh,
it's bad ass.
It was a complete rip off of like,
well,
it was not a rip off,
but trying to get on the bandwagon a star wars.
Oh,
states fiction.
What they have robots like r two d two is,
but they had that like paint them and make these big eyes on them and stuff like
that.
But they're pretty much floating.
R Two d two is,
it's pretty bad ass I would recommend.
But for being terrible bad ass.
Yeah.
For being
in though,
I don't wanna give it away.
The end,
the end is the worry about spoilers.
The printers will be happy to do different.
Mentioned nine nine at the end.
Just really fucked up.
And I would not ruin the end,
but the guy that did,
no,
it's fucked up.
You guys want to see this?
What?
You guys want to smoke a shitload of weed?
Didn't see the black hole.
I really don't.
You really will want it.
I gotta be in the right mood.
Clarify through.
I still got to it.
But the guy that did tron,
the neutron remake,
he's now redoing black hole.
Oh,
okay.
And so it's kind of kind of cool.
It wasn't John,
the neutron wasn't bad,
it wasn't great,
but it wasn't bad fun.
Or You watch the old one and I was like,
oh,
I don't have an interest in Washington was new thing.
Oh,
it's good.
Especially in three d three d was cool.
I saw a priest last night in three D I was,
I was priests.
Yeah,
it was priest who was a vampire killer dude.
Oh yeah.
That looks pretty.
Yeah,
it's fun.
It's fun.
It's stupid fun.
[inaudible] 17 Prajna to see it.
It's like a comic book movie.
You know?
I would say the hangover two.
Right?
Why Americarna why they have a thing there where you can get 130 different types
of sodas.
Whoa.
You choose your base like fantasy and a light sprite,
zero coke,
zero coke diet coke.
And then on top of that you so you can get like orange flavored caffeine free
diet coke.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Rape sprite.
Zero.
Whoa.
Yeah,
you can get,
it's,
it's awesome.
Oh,
I thought that for like 15 minutes.
Oh my God.
Girl I was with was like already people are wearing and I'm like,
you're gonna let them wait longer.
I haven't seen everything yet.
Wow.
All right.
Heel up the line.
I couldn't help it.
Horrible to be behind.
I know Ari,
he would dissect every single flavor got lost in it.
Yep.
Sorry you shouldn't put up that many if you don't expect people to look or how
about you let us send early.
I asked the lady specifically can I get in?
I'm high.
It's going to take me a long time.
And she said not until 20 minutes before the movie.
Have you seen the flashbacks sodas?
You told me you were hi.
Yeah,
I was like it's gonna take me a really long time to,
so what I want,
I'm really high.
Can I just go in now?
Have you seen the flashback?
So this they've taken like Pepsi and Mountain Dew and you can get rid of have
the old cans and then they have real cane sugar back.
Going back to,
do you think they should let stone people in movie theaters early?
SORTA like how they like babies on board pair plains early.
Yes.
Deal with it.
Cause you don't want me to Tuck in line behind me.
Wheelchairs and babies,
right?
Yeah.
With small children on quicker.
It's an impediment at certain point.
It's not a bad idea.
Are Do you think you overmedicate on marijuana?
Oh yeah.
No,
I mean,
I don't know what's overmedication.
What does that mean?
You wake up the second you wake up,
you smoke weed all day to the second email to slip.
You don't think he did that?
No,
I don't do that.
We don't do that.
What do you mean you don't think he does that?
I do,
but I don't to smoke a shit load of weed.
Every time I talk to you,
you're like,
I've already had,
well,
I just wonder,
call me a liar.
Yeah.
I'll tell you what I do.
I don't care if it's anything,
but I don't wake up and start smoking pot.
I usually take care of all my errands the way so I couldn't go to the bank.
The way you asked him was a tad on the Douchey side.
No,
no.
It's true fact that that Joey d is,
it does the same.
You know,
he wakes up and smokes weed all day and stuff like that.
I,
every time I hang out with Ari,
Ari is already completely baked out of his mind and it's like noon and I'm on
well maybe,
maybe he knows he's going to hang out with you.
He wants to get high and I to my pocket,
so let's just do it like I don't like to do it right before I go on it.
That's a legitimate question though.
But you said a Douchey overmedicate no,
no,
no.
Till later when he's,
you want me to do anything?
We've said,
I mean you wake up the first thing in the morning and I was like,
no,
I don't do that and just go,
okay.
You don't think you wake up first thing in the morning and smoke?
Yeah.
You said a clear use the word douchey question.
The truth of what I,
that's what I write.
The better way to do it.
Would it be too came across QC.
That's not what I was going to do,
but the important thing is,
the real question is how often are you getting high all day?
Like how many days I get high every day.
Every day.
Yeah.
Shazamm you don't take no days off.
Um,
very.
If I take a day off,
you'll probably hear about it.
It's a note worthy moments.
Yeah.
Well,
you know there's is,
and then I'm completely fine.
Right.
You know,
unless I get some honey butter like I got last night,
he'd been everyday.
Unless you get like a cookie.
Yeah.
Cookies in all day.
Look,
let's have some fun.
I went to six flags a couple of weeks ago or last week with Eric Abrams,
Xena,
and I'm a sickler sickler and we all hide some of those stuff from LCC,
the banana breads.
We were all friends did not rollercoasters.
It was so good.
I had about three quarters of one.
It was like,
oh,
choose us.
Oh my God.
I couldn't even imagine being that begged on a roller.
So,
so great.
Especially six flags.
Those are your hard codes are so extreme.
They have one where you strap in and they lift your legs up.
So you just flying,
only looked down into,
what is that one called x something that they have a job at x two.
I don't know if that was that one.
It might've been to the viper.
It was so fun.
It's so fun.
Season Pass,
you have to take everything out of your pockets.
You can't have nothing in your pockets,
man,
because that shit will go flying.
This is what I did this time around.
I said,
fuck it.
I'm gonna risk my glasses.
But yeah,
I had a Hoodie on.
I tied my glasses to the,
uh,
to the strings of my hoodie and they'd never fell off though.
They almost got flows,
but they never,
but I was like,
if they fall off,
fuck it.
I got to hold on,
I'm going to die.
Wow.
So it's like,
yeah,
but they never saw us.
They got close and then I managed to push him back.
Dude.
Deaths in amusement parks or like whenever you see that final destination,
you know those movies where people are dying,
it's always like a bunch of different,
I never saw one of them,
but I have seen,
I mean I think they must have done like five of them.
Yeah.
I always see the fucking,
the preview Marshall's a train hit somebody,
a bus flips over on someone.
There's not many deaths on roller coasters and stuff like that really,
but there is a lot of getting stuck and you don't see that much here.
Have you ever seen the video of like the people stuck upside down on a coaster
for four hour?
Oh my God,
that's worse than the fucking final destination flying off the track.
Can you imagine being upside down?
Oh,
happens all the fucking time.
Really?
Are you sure
you don't even have to report the dancer,
but no one dies on that.
Just worked.
No one got hurt.
Oh my gosh.
It's terrifying.
Cyclo was saying somebody's lost their cowboy hat on the ride and so jumped the
fence to get it.
Oh No.
And as he like got it.
He picked his head up,
decapitated and obliterated his head.
Somebody hit it with a foot like it was coming through.
One of those standing thing,
their foot got shattered.
I was like,
oh,
he just died instantly cause like leave your hat.
Oh my God,
I am the fence.
It are,
those things go like like three feet from the ground.
So people make some fucking terrible decisions.
Man.
People make some terrible goddamn decisions.
But yeah,
those are good
days for edibles.
You imagine the thought that went to that guy's mind right before that chick's
foot went through his mind,
back on my heart.
But death.
Do you even see it coming?
I say,
Oh my God,
I can't get outta here.
this is too close to the ground.
If you look right out as you,
as you pick up and they're just coming around where yeah,
it's and they go so fast.
Well I know the fastest one was in Abu Dhabi.
They just installed it and it was a,
a,
a Ferrari themed one because we did,
we did a UFC,
their Ferrari world.
And it's a big,
big crazy fucking rollercoaster with like,
you know what does that,
it sounds like your 400 miles an hour.
I think that's this one.
This one.
Maybe it wasn't.
This is the fastest one.
This is the newest,
newest and fastest.
There was one at six flags.
I said that.
Yeah.
This is probably as fast as the one you're talking about.
I think this one is new.
The one in Ferrari world.
I think it's like this year.
I'm pretty sure it's the fastest one out.
If somebody hits your head with a foot a hundred miles an hour,
lots of really fast and such for your foot to fucking God,
her leg shatter.
Cause she had to pick up his hat.
He's cowboy hat.
Yeah.
It just couldn't happen.
Nobody.
Hey my cats there is any way I can get it.
What a crazy story she'll have though.
No,
it freaks me out.
It said it was like those,
those traveling amusement parks that are in parking lots where out of nowhere
there's like this like roller coaster in the,
in the parking lot of a Costco circus already.
Yeah,
that's fake.
There's Mexican is the role of the store?
What's,
what's it got up mushrooms and went to watch it,
uh,
last week or the week before.
That shit scary man.
I remember my mom taking me to one of those as a kid and I'm thinking,
Mike,
mom,
that's like bad parents.
Somebody set that up.
You shouldn't be,
have control.
Like you should not be able to choose that for me.
Like I,
that's murder.
There was always those down I guess like in New Hampshire I got,
I'm trying to figure out where it would go and we'd go to one of the beaches,
one of the beach towns and there was like those little fucking carnival things
there and just really wonky roller coasters and shit where you're like,
really shouldn't be on it.
And it's just a rector sets.
They're not even real metal.
It's just erector set,
tons of work.
And they used to have like haunted houses and Shit and going through the shitty
haunted house.
I'm just terrible.
It's like a skeleton,
like a light bulb on it,
you know,
it pops up and I'm like,
yeah,
he's scared of me.
You fuck,
it's better than doing nothing.
We'll go there.
Exactly.
God,
I wish I could remember exactly what beach all this shit was on,
but there were just the one,
one whack ass ride after another.
They were all really awful just movements and they were all just waiting to go
flying off the tracks and in the stands and all the sleep with their big ideas
that work there would just disappear.
All the people that owned it.
You know what was really cool that I just thought of is that I don't,
I don't know how it was where you guys live by in haunted houses back in the day
and Columbus,
Ohio.
It used to be like,
oh that you remember that old house in the corner?
They're about to tear it down,
but they're going to make it a haunted house was still here.
And so like you go in this house and knowing how,
seeing it every day as a child,
what you know,
driving by that one old crazy house and then knowing it's going to get torn down
right after this haunted house.
It's feels like that house is just like even a thousand times more scarier.
I remember just going through these old houses,
like looking around going,
wow,
this is an old creepy house that needs to be torn down.
You know?
That's a cool idea.
Yeah,
fucking use it.
What's up with those dudes who do that shit on there on their front lawn on
Halloween,
like turned their front lawn until I got child molesters,
child molesters,
head of it.
There was one we went trick or treating and they had amaze.
This guy had built amaze.
I'm like,
this is a real trap built amazing amazes front lawn.
Have you ever been done at the Venice canals before?
Like Halloween?
No.
I'll do up their yard.
It was really awesome.
Really?
That and Christmas lights.
The Venice canals are supposed to be really nice,
but I know two people that live there that got robbed.
Really?
Yeah.
It's ever heard.
Houses got broken into that I could say.
Yeah.
Say it seems like right there.
It's like,
you know when you walked in the boardwalk in San Diego,
wherever and you're like,
oh,
there,
I can see into your living room right through this glass thing,
this living room that you're here only on weekends in the summer.
Yeah.
Well not only that,
there's a lot of 'em are celebrities and they say
f canal,
you know,
they want everybody to know where they live because I think it's like a hip spot
and then like Jesus stupid.
There's not that many houses there,
so people just go wandering around,
hey look at that.
That's that check from that fucking TV show.
Let's break in there.
Why not?
They know when you're working,
you're working all day.
You got a 16 hour day job.
Back cover onset.
Oh Great.
Awesome.
Will Rob your house?
Thanks for the heads up.
I can check off on your pillows.
Jewelry.
How many people did that turn off from their pillow?
If you are who you are and Megan Fox,
his house,
he would,
I would definitely at least go to the pillow and just go smell her underwear if
it was on the ground.
If you said it like that,
as you pointed to what underwear
do on my own,
you wouldn't take do on your own.
Is that something all guys do is smell?
I don't,
I'm not into it.
Pussy.
Yeah,
he's done it.
You've done it.
Of course.
I've done a lot of times.
Yes,
I've masturbated while it was shitting TB.
Never done that.
See if I could
teach scientific theory.
Proven
what Jason keeps his girlfriend's panties in a Ziploc bag when she goes out of
town just to keep the smell so she,
he can pull it out weird.
And I gave her a good tip and he like,
he was like,
thanks a lot for that tip.
He uh,
that before the girl leaves or Straw friend leaves,
Danielle needs to take her underwear and stuff at inside of her and it's so much
better for the smell.
Why don't you just go over there and blow him?
That's what you want to do.
Giving them tips.
Hey,
I know you're really fucked up and creepy.
What?
Underwear,
Daniel.
Here's a way to get a little more fucked up and creepy.
No bit more snake them and put them in a zippy.
Put them in a little Ziploc bag,
maybe like a little detail,
a little paper towel and moisten it.
Sort of like you would do you carry it home cigars?
Yeah.
You should do tire sheets.
Something that really holds the smell.
Yeah.
Holds the smell and
fucking lot's important because the smell of good pussy is delicious thing,
but the smell bad pussy is probably the worst smell you can smell next to like
some horrible chemical shit that's going to kill you.
Yeah,
the smell bat.
When you smell a girl and has a yeast infection,
that is easily the most repo.
It's worse than Shit.
It's a,
it's the worst thing to have to ignore.
It's a smell that smells worse than shit.
It really does,
right?
Wouldn't you agree?
It's like a worst smell and shit.
It's like it's nature's way.
Nature's way of telling you you don't want those kids.
It's like trying to scare you off.
Nature's trying to scare off.
The worst is when you look at what happens with those things,
right?
You get the,
first of all,
you get that shit on you.
You can get a yeast infection.
A man can get one as well.
You can get,
you can get it.
I mean realize what she's got down happens where I get to the yeast infection.
It smells,
it gets crazy.
It's going to get Dick is,
I think that's what they choose is what does that mean?
I think it's like some,
some stuff that's not supposed to be there.
Some sort of like creation excretion.
It's an itchy excretion.
Yeah.
It comes out of your Dick could be from all sorts of porn,
sex with a girl with cheeses upon them.
You can get,
Oh,
it's pretty easy for a girl to get a yeast infection too.
You know like when you see girls like putting chocolate syrup on them and like
porn videos and stuff.
That's sugar.
Sugar makes you that.
That gives you,
I can easily give you any eastern factor is the king of information on how to
fuck up.
I was like,
ah,
so obviously a,
that's how I got is about when you're doing those scenes,
which do come up in everyone's life,
you know,
lesbians,
bags of sugar or whatever,
whatever the afternoons stuff,
you're the king of that Thursday.
It's a weird thing.
Mandate.
Their bodies are like,
you know,
I mean we're all of our bodies,
we just don't think about it or you know,
housing,
all sorts of different healthy and non healthy friendly bacteria,
unfriendly bacteria,
you know,
all sorts of shut that shit on your skin.
And when you have any sort of an imbalance like that,
some sort of,
uh,
you know,
it could be for women,
it's like,
could be their diet,
it could be stuff they eat,
make some have yeast infection.
It could be the black shit underneath your fingernail and you just shove it into
that girl's pussy and next thing.
Yeah,
she's got wd 40 and poop inside place.
He exactly.
Or You could have a dog and she's allergic to dogs.
And you started finger banging around the inside of her pussy swells up in
itches.
You ate shrimp at fucking red lobster and she's allergic def.
Definitely allergic to red lobster.
Right,
and your red lobster comes out of your Dick.
Yeah,
it's still potent son tentacle porn if you like eight months.
Yeah.
It sounds like they're always going to get it no matter what.
But I'm wondering if you ate mushrooms and the chick blue you,
if she could get some of the frat.
Ooh,
I wonder.
I wonder if he could,
because I know that you could drink piss and the pis actually contained
siliciden and it actually takes a trip to the next level,
the sham,
and you're supposed to do it when you're full on tripping.
When you don't think you can get any higher.
You're
supposed to drink,
you're pissed.
When you drink,
It's all that silicide when that's gone through your system,
that gas passes through into your urine and urine is basically sterile.
It's people worry about drinking it,
but it's,
it's disgusting in thought,
but in reality it's really not that big a deal.
People drink it all the time to stay alive and they get stuck on boats and shit.
You know,
I mean you'd see the drink,
you're pissing live or dunk drink,
you're pissed and diet,
dehydration,
stupid.
[inaudible] sure it's gross.
But when you're high as fuck and you drink your past apparently the,
the mushrooms you into like another door,
you know like you know you went through the,
Brian had a breakthrough,
a mushroom trip that we talked about yesterday where he had like seven grams and
he,
wow,
really?
Seven grand.
The world dissolved and he became a part of some other world.
What,
how much that cost you
anything?
Those are the ones you got last minute,
Huh?
Those are the ones who got last minute kind of an inside conversation.
We're talking about a very important thing to have.
You know,
I was thinking about,
I saw the story of Pixar the other day.
She got it from Bob.
No.
Do you it from John.
What about Timmy?
I said,
I started,
started at Pixar the other day and he was talking about how creation a CGI is
all like triangles.
And when I was having that breakthrough on mushrooms the other day,
I,
that's what I was looking at my hand,
that everything was triangles and so animation,
like a person's face and stuff,
it's just tons and tons of triangles.
So I'm thinking,
wow,
what if I broke through and found out that I am a program and that's what I was
seeing my hand that was triangles.
Like I found,
I saw like the inner programming of my hand.
Well,
you know,
that's how that's lucky.
Huge scientific theory.
Believe it or not,
that the world,
the world is some sort of a computer recreation that our reality is not in
fact reality.
It's some sort of an artificial reality that sir,
it's all the major it's been created.
No,
it's not.
Even the Matrix is the matrix idea was that we were using like the human body,
you know,
they had to make it dark and discussing the human body had gotten stuck to this
machine and it was like there was sucking off by the all the biological program.
Yeah.
Well,
sort of,
but it was also sort of like a devious one that was like plotted to keep people
down.
And the idea is that the whole life that we're living,
like there is no real world,
is that every,
everything that you see and encounter is all just a part of your imagination.
All of it is.
And this world that you live in,
this world,
the,
the people that you interact with are all people that you've created in your
mind.
It just helps with the world.
And he would say,
well,
that's bullshit because I have my own world and I have my own juice.
So you're saying that I can do,
yes.
Yes.
That's the theory.
Theory is you have your own,
you're saying,
of course it's our universities interact with each other and we can change each
other.
Yeah.
Well there's,
there's a lot of wonky fucking ideas when it comes to,
you know,
what is reality and what is,
what is consciousness?
What is our place?
If you've built that university head that everyone else is just a part of your
head.
So they don't really exist.
They're just telling you no like no,
like in your world,
I'm just saying this,
but I don't really have any idea would be that there would be more than one
universe.
The idea would be that everyone would have their own,
like they're,
well you could call it a universe,
but we sort of have we some how or another coexist inside each other's universes
and that almost,
they're almost completely independent of each other.
But in when,
when they interact with each other they can change each other back and forth.
It sounds like total ridiculous hippy talk.
But if you,
you know,
if you look at like scientific interpretations of what a,
um,
some sort of a,
a,
a computer program of life would be and how detailed it could cat.
Well,
with the exponential increase in technology can get absolutely unrecognizable.
The computer simulation one day we'll end [inaudible].
It will be impossible to stop it from being as real as real life impossible.
So to say that we are absolutely not in that.
When we know what human beings are capable of.
We already talked about this cork glue on thing where they're,
you know,
this insanely dense battle.
We know structure.
That's possible.
Yeah.
We're just think it looks everything people fighting you and that's possible.
Oh that shit is possible with this.
We,
this might not be real.
It's,
it's possible that it sounds completely ridiculous and I'm absolutely agreeing
with anyone right now who's going,
this is what a total stoner talk.
Yes it is.
But it's also possible.
It's possible that reality is some sort of a computer simulation.
Okay.
So then what,
when I came out of it,
and it's a big question,
when I came out of being sick and puking and going through this phases of the
beat,
just being just like body was ill,
like out of nowhere,
I just became better and like,
like,
and I remember laying in bed,
we talked about this yesterday and I remember laying in bed going,
you know what?
I think I just died back there.
And then that in some other world and you and some other world you are just
like,
you know going,
oh my God you're dead and this is like a whole different,
like I was re I froze up and I was reset as my program was reset.
It might be because I felt like I was like,
wait a second,
why do I feel 100% right now?
And just a couple of minutes ago I was cause we bought our food out to the
person out there to this cap took to the cynic.
The people that this work you're doing,
you're jacking your brain with chem what goals and your five senses are being
overloaded at four limited
understanding of this reality and whatever the fuck else is possible out there.
Just relax on that.
I know what you're saying.
I'm with you 100% of course you're taking drugs in some wacky shit happens when
you take the drugs and you think it's real.
Hoe hippie.
What is death?
What is life?
What is,
what is the energy that takes us here?
What's really takes us into another place.
It's just the same thing.
It was like liquor where it's like you're just barfed and you feel better.
What is mushrooms?
It's something on which makes you think that that's what's interesting though,
right?
To worry about and
I know what,
what,
what I'm saying here is what everyone's worrying about is what sounds ridiculous
but they're not worrying about is how ridiculous our mushrooms in the first
place.
Right?
I mean you're talking about,
well it can't be the your ea,
you re reacting to a higher consciousness.
It's just chemicals and listen,
how crazy is it?
There's a fucking little plant that you can eat that can fuck your mind up so
deep.
How crazy is it?
Visits a little thing that's like that.
You can take it and it can take you to a cartoon world of impossible images.
That's his defense mechanism as a plant.
Is that what it is?
Yeah.
It's just like a Jalapeno pepper.
But why it makes you want to eat it.
It makes us want to eat it.
But then the years that had originally a counter,
it told them like,
don't cause it'll fuck you up.
Is that true?
Yeah.
Just like,
well,
you know,
I know that's true with hot peppers,
but did you know that the Ama Nita miscarrying is like the number one food for
Caribou?
They love really that crazy red and white snow man looking Santa Claus mushroom.
Yeah.
That's the one that they believe that yet the em and eat a mushroom.
This one from the sacred mushroom and the cross and that's the one that looks
like Santa Claus.
They love that shit.
They eat the reindeer.
A famous for it.
Really?
It just keep eating it.
Yeah.
That's how the whole Shamans,
Santa Claus myth happened with reindeer.
That's how rain they're going mix.
We'll see the whole idea,
and this if you haven't heard this,
it's a crazy theory.
I don't know how much of it makes sense,
but the idea is that this mushroom represents Santa Claus and that Santa Claus,
when you see this Santa Claus and you see him and he's like bringing new
packages under the Christmas tree.
Well that those packages as bright shiny packages,
what those packages are is those mushrooms have a microrisal relationship with
that tree with pine trees.
They grow under these fucking pine trees and they grow in the room,
the forest and people collect them and that Santa Claus was a showman and the
reason why they hung red stockings in front of the fire,
those aren't stockings.
Those are red mushrooms.
Those mushrooms are red and white.
Red and white there.
Yeah,
they are the colors of Santa Claus and that's how they dry them out.
They would hang them in front of the fireplace.
That's how they preserve on and that's also why they hang them on trees.
You hang them on trees to drive them out.
It's what you make of your reality as you're tripping out.
You'd like whatever that those drapes become fucking something.
A waterfall.
What's,
what's the poisonous one?
I thought the poisonous one was the emoney and Mascara is a little bit
poisonous.
Yeah.
I thought that was the one to stay away from.
Well,
when,
when I say poisons the l,
it's in the LD 50 rate.
You have to worry about,
you know,
you have to worry about toxicity.
There's some that looked like psychedelic mushrooms,
but they're really toxic.
You gotta be really good at,
right.
I think this is one system.
Yeah.
There's some that will fuck you up,
man.
But there's like,
it's all in like,
what kills us doesn't kill other things.
And what kills other things doesn't kill us.
You know,
like sheep,
sheep can't eat DMT.
If she sheep eat DMT,
they fucking fall down to the ground.
Their little legs stick up and you have seizures and die.
Yeah,
yeah.
If they eat grass that has a high DMT content,
they're fucked.
Wow.
Yeah.
Look at us.
We have it in our brains and we can smoke it and trip out and we'll,
you know,
relatively fine dogs can
eat chocolate.
You know what I'm saying?
So when,
when,
when they do like tests on other animals,
that's one of the things you have to consider.
Like,
man,
we're all so we've absolutely,
this would be a good time to promote shrimp fest.
Oh yeah.
That's,
so tell me about this shroom festival organizing international mushroom
festival.
Ah,
where are you going to do at 18th,
19th and 20th all over the world,
Joe,
whoever be oh,
people are just going to go on web cams.
Are you just going down?
We're all just doing shrooms together.
I think Brian's got a good,
yeah.
If people,
if people want to uh,
want to,
um,
what's it called?
Tape.
Schaaf take pictures.
Webcam.
Absolutely get involved in the community.
Yeah,
I'm Webcam it up man.
Yeah.
You definitely want people web cam in and Twitter's tech stores.
On Twitter.
We're going to have hashtag shrimp fest shroom fast.
So when I think goes down with your plans to Hashtag that's we can all look,
we can all sort of be together with it.
So how do you avoid getting arrested?
Well,
you know,
just like every time we do illegal drugs.
Yeah.
But this one,
you make it very vocal
getting arrested.
June 18th,
19th and 20th century.
Cheveria want to step out of the house please?
This is the door.
It's over here.
I know.
It looks like a giant gaping vagina with teeth.
This is the door I would be,
I would not be partaking ensuring fast.
Why would I do it?
No,
I just did it.
What if when you do shit to him more than once,
what if when you do shrooms or you enter into some sort of a zone or was,
if it wasn't true and maybe some other drug where there was a zone you could
enter where everyone was in the same hallucination of people say all the people
that are high who are out there,
shroom and all over the world,
a music giant world of Warcraft.
Dope.
When I'm not sure if that was at a music festival in Ottawa.
I wasn't sure who he was and as I was leaving,
as were all the whole crowd was leaving,
I could tell who else was on some sort of hallucinogen really in your head,
really?
In my head,
but I,
everyone's on just antidepressants.
He's on it.
I could tell.
I can tell you're the in the vibe.
No,
it's lovey.
Tra smiling.
I smile.
Nothing scares me more than those Abilify commercials.
Nothing scares me more than,
than Arriann Salvia.
Those Abilify commercials or commercials where you're,
your regular antidepressants don't work.
So you take this one,
what does that do?
And this one can make you suicidal,
homicidal.
It can make you a fucking,
uh,
a menace.
But it's for,
don't chew that shit up Brian.
It's for,
um,
people who uh,
who are regular shit ain't working for them.
Yeah,
it does.
People barely hanging on a lot of,
a lot of antidepressants.
Making suicidal.
What the fuck for real careful start to in slow doses.
How would I crazy catch 22 days side for the like,
so if you feel more than normal,
that tells me immediately you want to talk about Ren Salvia.
No,
let's finish what we're talking about.
True freshmen.
So yeah,
I've tried to get everyone to fucking do it,
to join it.
Tons of people at the commerce or doing it.
Tons of people.
Uh,
I might do it a couple times and I been big.
It's just 10.
We just got to sit in your house and do it or no,
no,
no.
I'm going to go explain to me shrimp fest.
What is the concept behind it?
And what are you talking to?
Everybody?
Let's go.
I'll fucking do it together.
So I'll do make an excuse just to do some shrooms that they're awesome.
I want you to experience them.
Here's the reason.
Just for the sake of the thing,
how many freak outs you think you're going to cause worldwide.
And I was planning it.
I was deciding when should we do this?
And I thought Monday would be the best day because let's stay away from the
squares.
There'll be at work,
let's get involved in it.
When so many people were asking me the light,
but I want to,
I want to do it,
but I can't take off a day of work.
Yeah man.
What year
your problem is,
you're only going to get the,
the uh,
the societal,
the outcasts.
So I added Saturday and Sunday.
Oh,
nice.
Monday,
Saturday,
Sunday.
What I would tell high school was over,
right?
So kids didn't have to worry about schools and finals.
Wow.
So somebody who's going to do something bad and they can blame you down.
You got to take responsibility for yourself and your own actions.
It seems like that's not a good idea to promote a day day.
Everybody come up for July 4th barbecue and somebody dies on the way there.
It's the same way.
It's like be careful.
Be careful.
Yeah.
There's this,
you shouldn't do it and drive.
Nobody should drive on mushrooms.
Absolutely not.
Cause that's the point.
You're making a good point.
Um,
yeah.
Don't do anything reckless at all,
but have some fun.
Organize a party,
go to a beach,
go to a barbecue,
go to a music festival.
There's worse things that we could do with our time.
You're talking about Portabella mushrooms too?
No,
I'm talking about psychedelic mushrooms and like know beans about bones,
about it.
I'm clearly talking about illegal mushrooms,
but I'm still saying let's all do it.
Start looking now.
Fine.
Just rooms.
Ask a waiter,
ask whoever would would your stoner friends don't know how to get it if you're
waiting or has more than one tattoo?
Yeah.
Ask Him.
That's a good source.
Especially if he's getting good tattoos.
If they don't have it,
they'll tell you where to get it.
You know,
if you tip well.
Yeah.
Well,
where would you go?
Would you go to a bar,
ask a waiter at a bar and that's the best move,
right.
I would say like a Houston's Houston's Houston's just because my roommate used
to work there and he was like,
yeah,
we all had wheat.
I would say guitar center.
That'd be a good idea too.
You have to convince them that you're not a cop.
Right.
Cause it's very weird.
Look.
Do you have any mushrooms through Google made a purchase from you,
sir?
There was another woman who was a,
a cop,
uh,
who,
coerce some guys in to getting her drugs and then they arrested the guys for
drugs.
Really?
Yeah.
The guy was saying that he could get,
it was in somewhere near San Diego.
I forget where it was and I bring this up because we,
yesterday we were talking about that ridiculous case where the woman went to
high school,
not just one woman,
but a bunch of different people went to high school and pretended to be a high
school students and they were cops,
undercover cops and they busted all these people for wheat.
Wow.
You didn't hear about,
damn,
that's a fucking rude man.
That's when you're just being the man.
What are you doing?
Why you ain't hurting the race so far more to come?
Fuck.
That's what my point is like
when you,
when you ask someone,
like say if you're talking to a,
a a child and you're an adult,
all right.
This woman has got to be like at least 19 to be a cop.
Right?
And she's talking to some kids how much smarter or using them when you're 19 and
they're 15 you're so much fucking smarter than them,
man.
You could talk them into doing all kinds of shit.
Yeah,
because you could talk them into it.
Dude.
You barely talk normal as well as when you got a mouth full of fucking dry food
or you,
that's why there's not far from you too.
What are you eating?
A cookie?
I have a basketball game tonight.
Oh,
nice.
Oh Park.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Okay.
What about this says it like we're just supposed to know,
but I played basketball at the park with all my comic friends.
Right.
I shot lights out.
I took a jolly rancher.
I look to hard before.
Oh yeah,
I was on fire.
I've never played that good.
Never not in high school.
Never been that good.
And it gives you a certain sensitivity.
Everything slowed down and the ball came at you like,
okay,
I can get to catch that.
Should I pass it on the word per shot?
Well here it comes.
I should grab it now.
You should try it.
Pool on it.
You tried pullo 92 my first poker tournament.
Dude,
you could play the fuck out of some pool when you're high.
Hmm.
You feel the boat.
I'm just never on an edible,
I don't think.
Yeah,
the edibles,
the way to go regular high is good,
but that there's something with the edible does to me is it?
It tunes the whole body in,
you know where as pot,
like when you smoke it goes blast right to your head and your high as fuck.
But it's not,
your body's not as in tuned the way it is with an edible.
Edible does something where the whole thing is hits the same frequency.
The whole you like you get a control over your body,
a feeling over your body.
That's why sex is so good.
Right.
Brian Edibles when your height squared.
Yeah,
it's crazy shit.
And he's jolly ranchers lately they just,
it's like doing banking banqueting immediately.
But yeah.
Wait,
what does that mean?
It just like super body numbness.
So you just let it lie there and just not feel anything.
It just,
everything feels numb.
Like it just make me stupid as fuck.
I can't take those things.
That part of it,
it doesn't,
it doesn't do that now.
It's just more of like a body part of the bike and that's all I associated with
veganism.
I got Viking is after my first ACL operation,
the first one I did,
they did what's called a Patella tendon graft.
And what that is,
is they take the Patella tendon is a really big fat,
thick tendon.
And what they do is they take,
uh,
they drill a hole and they cut the bone out.
They cut a section of bone out and slice the tendon and then cut a section of
the bone out where it connects.
And your Shin.
And then they open you up like a fish and they screw it into the bottom with a
screw and the screwed into the top of the screw and it's onsets and eventually
becomes like really strong like now.
But the fucking pain of the screws that they put in the bone of your shin is
hard to describe.
Man.
It's fucking hard to describe.
And I was lying on the couch.
I had my second one done with the cadaver and it's way easier.
It was nowhere near the pain,
but I would get off the couch and it would be like a law.
Like someone took a pitchfork and just dipped it in hot love or act.
It's just trying to just shoving it into your asshole.
Like that's what,
that's how bad it hurt.
It was fucking intense.
And so they gave me some Vicodin,
so every time I'd get up off the couch,
it was really temporary.
It would only last like maybe,
maybe 30 seconds or a minute,
but the fucking pain was on.
I never felt anything like that.
I had had broken bones.
I'd have I been sick.
I,
I've had a lot of like a real bad moments.
I
fucking got rid of him,
got rid of him after one day cause I took it and I was sitting on the couch and
I was so fucked up.
I was so dumb.
I was so dull.
I,
my mouth was open and I was watching MTV and I remember thinking I will never do
these again.
I don't give a fuck about the pain.
I don't ever want to feel like this.
I just felt stupid as fuck and I don't know man.
Maybe it's just me because uh,
the dudes at the pool hall loved them.
They bought those shits off me with the quickness.
Yeah man.
I before even fucking offered my friend Jeff was like,
hey bud,
I fair.
Hey do you got some viking ends?
You're trying to get rid of the other things but I can't you even fucking hear
you vultures.
They knew like,
yeah,
this stuff sucks.
I just did like other constipated me,
they give you constipation how many times he has done these things.
So I took it from my knee surgery.
I didn't take it for like a week or two.
Yeah.
And um,
I didn't get the crazy stupid stuff,
but I did get a,
you had a meniscus meniscus?
Not that.
Oh,
you're a bone crack.
Yeah.
Ooh.
Had the bone crack.
It's all,
I don't know if that's all he'll hooked or something.
There's somebody catch you in something.
I don't,
I honestly think it was kettlebells,
kettlebells,
and the next time to kettlebells after I came back from PTO therapy,
I could feel a tweak real was like,
I should,
this is what it was.
I thought it might've been the more,
cause I was like,
it was around the same time as I did some of those,
um,
they really out to your power,
but your problem,
once you went for like this long period of time where you weren't in shape and
then all of a sudden you threw yourself into Jujitsu class.
Yeah.
It was after like a year though.
But right away we were still getting,
you were getting some breakdowns,
you know,
it's hard and you don't,
you don't eat that good.
No.
You know,
we talked about that.
Like,
I'm like,
if you really want to do this,
you have to take vitamins and you have to eat well.
It really trying to get my candy.
I'd take to where I want.
Where's it at right now?
Well,
I'm suffering greatly.
The juicy fruit category,
GG fruit,
all the sort of [inaudible] was a fan of anything other than chocolate.
Why try other things?
Oh,
I got bored with life,
man.
Get out there and try them.
You know,
I try like a go crazy.
Get a little sour patch kids and I was like,
fucking melon.
Grab some chocolate
gummy Belen ranks.
Hmm.
Not really a melon rings fan.
Squirty Gumby squirty gummy bears.
A peanut branch.
I have the same voice in the same conversation when he's 80 Oh squirty gammy
verity.
Melanins slices.
They're all gonna think he's a pedophile.
It's like,
let's say I just never grew up in the same time.
Like tell us about nine 11 well these terrorist,
the binos that was back when you can get Twizzlers at the corner store the gas
station,
get Twizzlers before they need them.
One day.
Twizzlers,
stop paying the other government.
Just to be able to eat those.
They do nothing but bad for you.
Gavin,
come in,
bitches.
No,
your shit's poisonous.
Shut everything down.
The twizzler factor.
I mean we look,
someone has to come to the,
the absolute conclusion that that's what's happening with cigarettes.
There's no other fucking way.
Cigarettes would still be legal.
They are.
They are paying the government to keep cigarettes legal.
There's just no way around it.
If there's one thing that's killing 350 to 400,000 people every year,
year,
Americans,
worldwide,
Americans wrap your head around that.
Richard Thousand Americans.
Every 300,000 Americans plus every year,
so that's like dead from cigarettes.
A 10th of 1% of the country.
Well look,
they were going to die every thousand people.
Yeah,
every year.
Oh yeah.
Wow.
That's a lot.
Yeah.
That should totally be illegal.
Then she'd give you like a year,
I'm pulling this out of my ass,
so we'll just,
it's everything.
It's every six and a half minutes.
Somebody dies in America or the world,
I don't know.
You don't know every 617 the rogue red smoke?
I'm just guessing like why?
Why even saying cause I can't imagine the commercial going.
Listen to this.
Here's the,
it's even crazier.
It's even crazier.
Worldwide tobacco deaths are more than 5 million per year.
Wow.
Whoa.
Now how many of those are accounting somebody?
Here we go.
The most recent statistics America 2011 yeah,
443,000 us deaths attributed.
It's only been,
it's only been five months.
No,
each year they're saying each year.
Sorry,
I didn't read the full full sentence to you.
What does that,
each year an estimated 443,000 people die prematurely from smoking or exposure
to secondhand smoke and another 8.6 million live with a serious illness caused
by smoking.
Wow.
Oh yeah.
They'd have people like that.
They don't die,
but they have trick Ya,
dude.
That is not just tracheotomy.
How about people of iron lungs?
How have people that are slowly dying or is that still around?
I saw an iron lung.
You see him at the airport,
man,
they're,
they're carrying around or there's some people that have iron lungs.
Yeah.
The thing with it forces you to breathe in and out.
I'm sure that exists,
but how about the people that are connected to those tanks?
Bring them everywhere.
Things in their,
in their nostrils.
And you know what it is,
man,
I saw it going down at the gun ranch.
He had that thing in his scooter in the back.
That's to his rifle.
It was also in the bag.
Well for some people I shouldn't say you know who it is.
Cause for some people I'm sure they have to use that because of an actual
disease they didn't get from switching.
But,
but it's amazing man.
Those numbers are really scary.
It's the numbers or the trippy thing about him is that it's never discussed.
You know,
they'll talk about 3000 people that died during nine 11 and no one's saying that
that's not a big deal.
It is a big deal and it's a horrible thing.
But 443,000 people are reacting to death,
choking on their own fluid.
That's building up in their rotten lungs.
They drown.
They drown in their own fluid.
They literally can't get oxygen into their lungs anymore.
They fill up with fluid and they die a horrible death.
They have to strap them down.
That's a thousand people a day.
That's more than a thousand people a day.
[inaudible] crime,
Annie.
Yeah,
that's a lot.
Yeah.
That should totally be able to go.
That should give you some time.
It's so scary,
right?
Six months,
six months to a year.
Yeah.
We were like,
it's going to happen here.
Six months.
I don't think it should be illegal.
I think you should be able to do whatever the fuck you want.
On the second hand,
smoke makes me,
makes me second.
They're doing in terms of like not,
not in public.
That's scary.
When you have a,
you know,
a spouse or children and you know your smoking and your apartment.
That's a lot of people are doing that and those kids are getting sick.
Yeah.
That's a scary thing
then.
Do you know it's against the law now in California to drive in a car with anyone
under the age of 18 I mean if it's your own kids and smoke cigarettes.
Yup.
Oh,
in smoke?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
It was like,
what are you doing?
What the fuck you talking about?
Why you taking kids to school?
That's where it
really gets where we got only one way to keep kids from fucking do.
Just to keep them at home.
Don't drive them around.
Fuck No.
That's one thing I do remember as a kid Mike,
my friend's mom always driving us to the bowling alley every weekend because we
are in a bowling league and smoking the whole way there with the windows open
and as a kid I remember God,
this is disgusting and I told my mom the other day about it know you are
smoking.
Yeah,
that's exactly it.
Probably one of the reasons why that or my grandfather always smoking.
Everyone slept around way kid.
That's definitely not why.
The reason why is because you had a cigarette in your mouth and you smoke it.
No,
but that's why you're smoking a cigarette.
The reason I ever got to the point where I would do that is because I grew up
with all everyone around me smoking.
I grew up around people smoking.
My mom smoked when I was a little kid.
She quit.
She quit when I was like 10 something like that.
I got to see her smile eventually.
If they were completely legal,
like wailing when I was born,
if there were illegal,
I would have eventually got into,
I would have like found one and try to,
we all try them together when I was like 15 yeah.
My sister,
my sister stuck with it for a long time,
man.
She kept smoking for years,
so she quit now,
but fuck it ain't,
it's not easy,
man.
You know everybody,
Brian will tell you,
Joe,
you'll tell you,
you can tell everybody you know,
you can.
All,
you guys are both.
You're currently addicted and you were,
you know your debate.
We're covering six months or a year.
It's still open.
It's just amazing.
It's amazing that the government can somehow or another allow this,
that they can pretend they're looking out for our interests there.
You know,
stop fucking high school kids from selling weed and get some people pay our own
tax dollars.
Should have some chick played 21 jump street,
you know,
and going and,
and,
and get some weed off.
Some kids.
They didn't even uncover anything other than weed.
That's cool.
You know what that makes me,
that makes me happy about our new generation.
The kids coming up.
Yeah.
They got arrested for weed,
but look,
what are they doing?
I get some weed and trying to bang some cop.
That's right.
Exactly.
I'm trying to get laid.
I had just people at central Washington,
my show that were,
uh,
that uh,
they had no teeth and their smile.
Whoa.
So I was like,
hey,
we got a on that situation.
And he goes,
he holds up his drink.
He goes,
seven years sober,
man.
And I was like,
fuck yeah.
I was like,
wait,
you're holding up a beer
had already said to me,
he goes,
you don't think it's a difference between a fucking drink at a comedy club and
Meth?
And I was like,
you're absolutely right and I apologize.
There's a complete difference.
How funny is that,
man?
Yeah.
How funny is that?
Yeah,
and I was like,
you know how even sober?
I'm like,
fuck.
Of course you are.
Hey,
you need to take her advice from that.
A little Esther chick,
she says a lot of cool shit on Twitter.
Revise the advice.
Here's what little Esther just said on Twitter.
Everyone that's in a relationship is delusional.
Will last her stop.
Move away from the fucker keyboard.
Right.
This is getting too transparent.
I'm starting to feel ill.
There's a new breed of people who love taking ship public.
I love like we're throwing shit out there.
That's just silliness.
Just so the person who has offended them,
we'll know they're talking about them.
There's a little of that.
That's a little bit I'm sure.
And then statement.
This is also,
that's the kind of thing that you say when you're 21 you think you really have
an answer.
That's the saddest thing about life.
You get older,
you get more questions,
you know,
you realize you accept that there are no answers to a lot of things,
so you just able to accept that.
That's a tough fucking cell man.
That one moment we have to give in and accept that there are no fucking answers.
I mean,
we all know that that's what turns people to religion.
you were very,
you were much more religious than I was when I was a kid,
but I was very religious for a little while when my parents were breaking up and
I was five before I went to Catholic school and they cured me.
Yeah.
They cured me in Catholic school,
the surge of religion,
fucking cunt,
none.
These evil woman,
this woman was,
she was just rot rock.
That's what she wants.
She was Rochester,
Madge Josephine.
She was just rocked.
She was a rotten person,
like everything was bad about her.
She started yelling at me the first day in fucking school.
God,
she was just evil man.
She was just an evil bitch.
She's dead now.
You think?
How old was she though?
She was old as fuck.
She was old as fuck when I was like,
I was like six,
you know?
But I remember thinking like why I was getting through school.
Well,
you know,
every day I lived in terror.
It was just fucking so mean.
But while I was getting into school,
I remember thinking,
well now I have to like figure out what the fuck is going on because clearly
it's not religion because I thought when I went to church,
when I was a little kid,
when I was like three and four and five,
you know,
church to me was like,
my whole life was falling apart and my parents were getting divorced.
I didn't know what was going on.
My Dad was super violent and I was just starting to realize that he'd beat my
mom up for no reason.
So to me like there has to be God,
there has to be something,
you know?
I would go to them when I would go to church with my grandparents or with,
you know,
whoever took me,
I would,
I would say,
well this is this beautiful,
you know,
everybody here is being nice and,
and God be with you.
And they're all saying nice things and you know,
and if,
and they're telling me if you do the right thing,
you'd go to heaven
and all the sins on earth,
you know,
disappear and dissolve.
But this cunt was so evil and she was connected to this.
I was like,
wow.
She was like the shittiest salesperson for religion all time.
They don't get the right spokesman.
But that's like one of the cool things about being Catholic.
Well,
you'll get the religion is so ridiculous.
Very few people completely agree with it.
It's so over the top.
Stupid and ridiculous and mean.
There was a story last week about one,
one of the head guys and the pope's a whole thing about pedophilia got arrested
for pedophilia.
This motherfucker got arrested for,
uh,
he was trying to get a Moroccans to deliver him young boys and he was telling
them to get them from kids who had a troubled childhood.
What was his position on this shit
charge of pet.
The pedophilia have to make sure that the priest didn't do it.
Like he was the guy that the pope I put in charge of making sure that doesn't
happen.
He was there,
he was there.
Uh,
what's the branch of the cops and I forget the,
no,
I've watched enough TV,
Peter Protectors.
But yeah,
so there is a story,
a priests in the archdiocese of a top advisor to pope benedict the 16th.
What is,
he was arrested Friday on a pedophilia and drug charges and they have all the
papers of this dude asking for,
uh,
for,
they have like emails and shit of him asking for boys and wanting them from
backgrounds where they're there.
You know,
it didn't have a family and they're all fucked up.
How ridiculous is that?
The guy that was in charge to make sure that didn't happen?
This is his,
this is his.
This is one of the things you wrote.
I do not want 16 year old boys,
but younger 14 year olds are okay.
Look for needy boys who have family issues,
who's trading cocaine for boys and that the Vatican knew about the problem for
decades.
Listen man,
they're all creepy.
That's the worst part.
I understand.
If a priest does nothing,
that's not the whole organization's fault.
Dude.
They've been doing this shit forever,
man.
They were doing this shit forever.
This,
I mean they just,
they gathered back it up here.
If you don't arrest them and you're backing it up.
This pope,
when he was a bishop,
this one that's currently in now,
they're,
they have all sorts of paperwork showing that he was shielding child molesters.
He was moving,
he was moving them from one place to another and and and trying to get them to
avoid a prosecution.
My amazing,
it's amazing that anybody would take any of this shit seriously,
that it's still you.
They can still do this and they can still have meetings with Obama and the good,
everyone can still pretend this isn't something that's evil and you're going to
tell me,
yeah,
it's a fucking cult of kid fuckers.
That's what it is.
Why is this not like on the front page of CNN?
Why is that?
The only article about this was from some,
you know,
translated from some Italian newspaper,
like why aren't they collecting all these facts and like really talking about
this on mainstream news,
isn't it?
Some of it might be also people are just tired.
It's the same
story for the last 1520 years.
It was in the New York Times just trans.
No,
it did.
They just translate the articles.
When I was saying I is there actually anybody really talking about this other
than translations from Italian newspapers,
you know,
I don't know,
but there's been other stories about these in the New York Times as well.
It's not like people were avoiding the,
all these put these pedophile issues and they,
there was also like in every mainstream story or every mainstream,
a new source.
There was some big meeting that they had recently to deal with the priests and
sexual charges and that was all public to out a certain amount of it has to be
public because it's such a known issue.
If you're out there are go to Catholic churches,
you're going to an organization that condones this behavior.
So just know that when you show up for church tomorrow.
Yeah,
absolutely.
You're joining an organization that can don't that behavior.
You know,
what the fuck,
what are you doing?
It's amazing,
but you really are.
Yeah.
They're like,
oh,
I'm still saying that with child molesters in my organization that are making
the rules for me,
but I'm not leaving this organization based on fairy tales.
Well,
based on who the fuck knows what the original thing was to believe in Jesus,
you clearly know these people are.
Yeah.
Just go to a nondenominational church or something.
Well,
they're not acting in Jesus's name when they're fucking your kid's mouth.
It's that simple.
That's right.
It's amazing how many people can get away with.
There was,
um,
the bill Maher had a clip that somebody put up online from his show that that
made a really good point.
And,
uh,
he was talking about how many people call themselves Christians but don't follow
any of the rules of Christianity.
Well,
he was talking about the Osama bin Ladin thing.
Like Jesus was like the most nonviolent guy ever,
you know.
And he was the guy who said,
turn your other cheek,
you know,
don't do not be evil to your enemies,
which we've done with love.
And meanwhile,
the Christians go into kill Muslims,
guns and horses on,
uh,
on boats.
Yeah.
And he was really funny because Obama,
they asked to Obama about people that would,
you know,
whether you know,
what's the controversy about the death of Osama bin Laden?
And he was like,
anybody to think there's anything wrong with getting rid of that guy.
And it needs to have their brain checked.
It needs to have their head checks.
Like this is a guy who pretends to be a Christian.
This was like Bill Maher's point.
And it's such a good point,
you know,
because it's like the most neglected aspect of Christianity as well as like,
you're not supposed to hate,
you're not supposed to be angry at people and you're,
you're supposed to be all turn your other cheek and not just love,
love your enemy.
Love
what does it man.
Yeah,
take your enemy,
the guy who you hate and not just forgiven but love him.
Yeah.
Well really it's awesome advice.
Why did they capture that guy?
Jesus?
No,
Osama bin Ladin is definitely trying to capture Jesus.
I don't think it's real.
I don't,
I mean,
I don't know if it's real.
It might be real.
They might have done exactly what they said and they might've killed Osama bin
Laden at that moment.
But you know,
there was a,
there's a lot of,
like,
there was a lot of reports like way back to 2002 that that guy was dead and they
were always saying that he was very sick.
You know,
they're always saying that that guy had,
you know,
a bad kidneys and he needed dialysis on a regular basis.
I don't think they took the chance of him hostily being out there to say like
unless they know they've seen his body,
there's no way.
Oh,
let the president go on and say,
I assure you he's dead.
If like it might come up that he's not.
Do you?
Yeah,
but that w w if he was already dead a long time ago,
that's what they believe.
What people believe is that this was just some sort of like,
oh,
this is some sort of a publicity ploy to keep.
Look,
Obama is like this.
This ingenious device,
if the Republicans have created get is,
get a guy run for the Democratic Party,
make them black and make them do everything a republican would do.
Yay.
And everybody loves him and he's,
he's fucking you and you're clapping.
Yay.
He's the black president.
Meanwhile he's fucking Bush.
Plus he's doing everything that Bush did.
Plus he's doing exactly the same shit.
My problem with the theory that like you just did this to win an election that's
coming up.
It's like,
well,
if they're going to do that,
the timing is not right.
Wait.
Maybe it is though.
Maybe it is because maybe this is what sets the ball in motion.
Maybe they have like political experts that have actually studied like tides of
the cult of personality and how many times,
how many months does it take?
Maybe like all this shit with Kim Kardashians and all this,
this is this,
this is us.
All the government has done is create these famous people for no reason.
Just so he could see like chart the tides of how,
how much time does it take for people to get pissed off at you and how much time
does it take for you to recover from that?
You know,
and everybody was pissed off at Obama.
How much time does it take him to recover and be a bad mother fucker gun?
Well,
he's got to kill bin Laden now and then it needs like nine months for it to
fester in the American psyche.
And this is step one of a bunch of other things that we'll send to the place.
Perfect time to do it.
Yeah,
they're wagging the dog.
That's first step one,
they kill som in law and that's awesome.
Now step two,
they're going to thwart some nuclear attack.
They'll stop that look like bad asses.
Ariel Dab Republic re.
Yeah.
And then they move into step three,
and then the announced all these new jobs because the government will hire like
2 million census workers.
The government created 2 million new jobs.
Meanwhile,
it just a bunch of people knocking on your door and knowing you and asking you
what peanut butter you use.
You know,
I was like,
you put it on a fucking sensors.
That's why the only thing they could have beat,
beat Obama would be something like a lesbian armless lesbian,
armless lesbian.
Nobody wants an armless woman.
I think a lot of Republicans,
Shit Obama on this blacklist doing it.
I'll do it in four years.
I'm not running against Obama.
I think a lot of people would be good to run against Obama if they would like
Ron Paul.
Did you know Ron Paul and that other guy from New Mexico,
the former Gary Johnson?
Well,
first of all,
both of those guys are,
you know,
the Republicans.
Um,
I,
I'm pretty sure Gary Johnson is,
but I know that,
um,
what do you mean Ron Paul?
Like what do you mean?
What does that verb mean?
Ron Pauling it,
well Ron Paul is all about smaller government and is all about getting us out of
these wars and is all about being honest about what's happened with the American
people and then upholding the constitution and freedom,
uh,
of,
of uh,
uh,
personal use of drugs and doing whatever the fuck you need to do.
And we're getting a new constitution made by people that we can relate to.
That would help,
but it didn't then it would be a question of who would be the ones that would
draft his fucking thing and how much would the government have a say in it?
You know,
cause you,
when,
when they come up with things like the Patriot Act,
you can't think that they're looking out for your best interests.
So we can't let them coming up,
come up with a new constitution.
So who the fuck,
I mean,
the,
the system right now is so corrupt.
You can't say,
hey,
you guys are all corrupt and fucked up.
We please fix this right outside of quiet.
It's a good point that people in charge,
we've got to be.
So who would it have to be?
We didn't have to be scholarships with the people.
Well,
they've shown time and time again that a lot of these guys,
especially when it comes to economics,
that are professors at universities,
they're not only,
they don't know shit,
they're horse.
All these guys that,
especially the professors and,
and uh,
economics in a,
that are detailed in that movie,
the inside job think whatever money they go,
oh my God,
these guys are getting paid left and right by all these different,
these professors in economics get paid to like sign off on these,
these different like trusts and different funds and different,
you know,
and,
and sign off on these different ideas and work for major corporations in the
future.
And they get these huge cushy fucking jobs,
like millions and millions of dollars.
So they say all these things that are complimentary towards certain styles of
the market and they teach certain things that would encourage,
you know,
the same sort of a system that they have set up or had set up for a long time
until this recent economic collapse and they endorse it and they say,
Oh,
this is rock solid and this is everything's fine.
And it turns out if you follow the paper trail,
these motherfuckers are,
all of them eventually wind up getting cushy jobs.
It's all,
it's a,
it's a real sneaky snaky situation.
Francis,
anytime you see an economist on the on Good Morning America or anything or
whatever,
talking about meet the press,
talking about whatever it goes there,
they're selling a book that's selling some books that sounds something.
So they need to say something that's incendiary enough that they can get on
those shows to sell more books.
Right.
She'll,
we go get it in culture.
She's a fucking professional troll.
She's professional at it.
She goes on,
she says a bunch.
She's the,
the the like vulture ish looking.
She's pretty,
if you're drunk.
Oh,
she's the thinner one with the straight hair.
Yeah,
like you might hate fucker.
Yeah.
If you were in San Diego and you were drunk,
you know she was at a bar.
I think you're funny and you're dirty.
June was suck your dirty Jew cock.
If she touched my dick on the way by to the bathroom,
like gently by,
I'd be like,
oh,
we thought she would do.
No.
If she did,
then I would definitely get out of here.
Really.
Would you call her again afterwards or would you feel gross?
It was actually an culter.
We'll just start with not just someone who looked like that.
Would you start bringing it around the store?
No,
you should really cool man.
The,
a lot of that shit is just her public image.
She's playing a character who she is though.
She is.
I mean,
she's very smart at it.
She says a lot of incendiary shit and it's funny,
you know,
and she,
she called Bob Edwards a faggot.
Well,
no way is it Bob Edwards?
It was.
She got John Edwards.
Yeah.
She called John Edwards a faggot watts.
She said he's still got a job.
You waited?
Yeah man,
she's white.
She's a Republican.
It's all good.
She sat on the air.
It was really funny that she had to Apollo.
Jimmy Norton had a good joke and you know like a a wonder why she thought that
maybe she saw him more than twice.
What do you mean?
Well guys,
it looks like a faggot when we made her say that.
I wonder,
I guess she saw him more than twice.
I don't know what that guy looks like.
What did,
I love that the phrasing of that that's enough to like you start assessing them.
What the fuck's going on with this guy here?
Oh He's good.
He's the guy that was wife was dying of fucking cancer or that guy having a baby
with some other chick.
I have wonder man.
Back before we were just getting sort of seat to see now how many dudes were
we're rocking it like that.
All of them.
Why wouldn't they?
I think that was just a part of the way it was done.
I mean like when you go back to like the Kennedy's sort of like,
everyone knew,
you remember when we were kids,
we were growing up.
We kind of all knew that Kennedy Fuck Marilyn Monroe.
Right.
What are new but didn't say anything.
Yeah.
Well it was,
it was sort of like one of those things.
It was just like,
it was,
uh,
we,
we would just say,
oh,
there's a different time.
I think back when they had no accountability,
they can just get away with shit.
Like a lot of politicians are in the position of getting laid.
They do it,
you know,
you've seen a movie,
see some cop fuck a hooker Zombie be like,
oh,
that's normal.
But then you actually see a police officer.
You're like,
no way.
Right,
but why not?
That's who's doing it.
Regular people are doing these corrupt things that you would think,
no,
not them.
Sluts till you see come across a slut and full,
full,
you know,
as long dress or something.
Like,
no,
she wouldn't be like that.
Yeah.
There's sites get regular jobs.
They're all around us.
That's where our women are terrified when their husbands go to the office.
There's always had one crazy bitch.
It'll suck your Dick and a stock room and who's going to resist?
Yeah.
I mean you might live your whole life and never meet one or you might work for
the right office.
And this girl's crazy and she shows you a picture of her pussy on her cell phone
and you're like,
what the fuck are you doing when you show me that for the next thing you know
it,
you're sure seem flirty.
[inaudible]
Eular,
he knows the best at picking those girls.
Oh,
Joe Diaz.
He can spot them a mile away and there she is right there.
That dirty freak.
I could see it.
I can see it.
Her eyes,
Joe Rogan per age.
I call my Dick.
Oh,
he had the crazy stories yesterday,
man,
about trying to pass drug tests or putting various substances,
uh,
over his dick and then covering it with his four skin dropped into Dallas.
So then it would all drop into the Piss Cup while he was pissing.
And we've taint the last two weeks.
Yeah.
He would like add like chlorine.
He added chlorine.
He had a dream.
If you put it in there,
he's putting Draino under the under is essentially put a rubber band around it
and burn some extra pain.
No.
Yeah,
like the whole,
the whole thing.
I was,
I was trying to picture in my head and it made no sense.
It was,
it was like,
does he put it in there and then tie it in a,
not a team with his skin really did that.
He was just joking.
How,
but is this date attached to it?
Apparently he said he has a big four skin.
His foreskin is very long,
so he just stuffs it up there and let it sit there.
Bass,
I don't have a dick like I can to [inaudible] been around since that.
Alright.
Well I think normally when it's soft it's covered over login an eater.
So any let it gets hard then.
Yeah,
mate,
look,
some stuff,
whatever you got in there.
He's like,
first the chlorine was our crumples.
It was like coring crumbles from like one of those things that you like drop
into a pool to chlorinate the pool.
Okay.
Something like that.
Like shaved it and then he put that stuff under his dick was my one year old
nephew just had to go under the knife for a second time to do his circumcision.
And we had talked about this before and what happened is the first time they did
the circumstances,
it didn't take,
it started to grow back together or do something.
I don't understand what they were talking about.
So they had to put my nephew under and uh,
do plastic surgery,
cut off more and blah,
blah,
blah.
And my biggest thing,
I was just like,
wait a second,
you know,
like this is a high tech hospital.
Why is this happening?
How is this happening?
Why,
why couldn't you just,
I told my mom to get the oldest June,
give them a $100 and that would probably be better than,
than,
than high tech hospital.
She had herpes and it'll suck your kids.
Did he know that?
That's how they do it.
They cut it off,
then they suck on it.
Who Sucks on it?
The oil sucks on the deck.
Yes.
You don't know that,
that the ancient Hasidic practice of they,
when they believe it's acidic,
they,
when they,
uh,
the guy who was,
what's,
what's the guy's name?
The cuts,
your Dick Oil.
The oil when it's supposed to suck it,
that's how they're supposed to like stop the blood are the ones that I've seen.
Just these towels.
Yeah.
They suck it too though,
Dude.
The traditional ways to suck it.
There was a whole,
um,
there was a whole story because a baby died of herpes because the guy had herpes
on his mouth.
He had a cold sore in his mouth and he does the traditional way and he sucks a
little kids.
Dick like Pete,
it sounds like,
it sounds like I'm talking crazy.
It's crazy.
But it's,
there's the real thing.
Spell Moyle,
Spellman Moy,
Ellie,
e.
L.
I'm going to white here.
It was Moy Eeo.
I guess I've seen a lot of times I've never seen that before.
It gets here.
Is this a new practice now?
This new way to do circumcisions that that hospitals have been doing in the fail
rate is so much higher.
But I guess it's more sensitivity for the kid and all that.
It's super safer.
But the crazy thing is,
is that doctors say to each other's doctors,
it's an art.
Like it's,
it's,
it's a guessing game.
You have to be so good at it and it just experience.
Yeah.
There's a video of a guy explaining why the Moyle has to suck a boy's penis
after circumcision.
So if you go to look up on um,
on a online,
on youtube,
go to youtube and write in rabbi explains the importance of sucking.
Explain.
I'd love to hear this.
Yeah.
Explains,
explains
the importance of sucking a boy's penis.
Yeah.
I see.
I didn't make this shit up,
man.
I would love to hear this.
Some ridiculous nonsense.
How'd you find this?
Me Start with
the argument with and get an argument with the wife.
Hide in the office.
Shit gets dark.
Shark bites boys oil a day.
And that's the second section.
A little loud.
It's a little loud for integrations of the pull the show.
Does that table in chapter two 66,
uh,
I love the three,
four,
five and six.
He describes how the circumcision is to be done.
This is after the cutting.
The mogul does what's called the [inaudible] means to suck.
It means to doing so with his mouth.
I want to say,
well,
why can't you use a tube while you could technically,
but it's not the customer as to why,
how it was done.
Now why is it that way?
It's sending the oldness.
You didn't have to.
Now you can have two.
So why not?
The answers I thought about it is that it's not as effective because the tube is
interpreting this right Neil as well.
It's not as pliable and furthermore,
it's not as quick and it's not as close.
You have to have a quick suction action.
You have to have more pliability.
No.
So there's the theory.
Some people feel that it is.
Some people feel that it's not that the saliva of a human being has some
antiseptic qualities and it's
in the never heard of
making up reasons why he thinks it should be.
And so
that's what he would have has elements of cleaning of antiseptic
yell at him.
That's sick.
Fuck sucking little babies.
Dicks.
Yeah,
that's not right,
but,
but um,
this is a,
this is the tradition,
correct?
No,
no,
I've never heard that term.
And that might've been what they did.
What he said was that he was reading out of a passage of a book that said that
that was what you're supposed to do.
[inaudible] read out of the pastors and this is the passenger and then he then
interpreted what he thinks that should be no,
he was pretty clear that he said,
it says to suck.
Yeah,
you're supposed to use the device because why not?
Device goes,
well,
maybe it's not as good.
He didn't say what the mouth,
he said you can use a device,
you can use something else.
But he goes,
it's tradition not to,
he's interpreting it right there on that video.
But didn't it say in the scripture to suck it with the mouth?
No,
he said to suck and that means then with the mouth.
Huh?
He clearly says that you can interpret it just says suck.
Okay.
I don't want to listen to it again to,
uh,
to like figure it out.
But I don't,
I don't think,
I've never seen that either wonky.
Is it though?
You're cutting babies.
Dick's and sucking on them.
So it's like the whole thing is never heard.
What a ridiculous thing it is.
Like,
I mean people will say like,
if you have a boy,
would you circumcise your kid?
No.
Why would I?
And the loads is Dick's going to look
ugly?
Like what are you doing staring at People's decks by the time someone gets your
Dick,
okay,
look what?
What's the difference?
There's a little skin that's going to throw you off.
Good.
Get outta here.
You're crazy cleaner,
right?
It's cleaner.
And Joe,
you know,
like most people do have,
are circumcised,
you know that,
right?
Yeah.
Because there's reasons for it.
I like my nephew had so much skin.
It's because there's reasons.
My nephew had so much skin that like there would be no way to clean his dick
unless you know about your nephews for skin size.
Me and my mom had a conversation about it and we actually talked about my
nephews p and s for a half hour.
Then we started talking about my penis in my,
my mom said that the doctor that did my dick used to always brag to her about
how good he was at circumcision.
He was like an artist and then so my mom goes,
he,
he did a good job.
Right.
All right.
What are you doing?
Oh,
sorry to hear that.
My mom actually goes,
he did a good job,
right?
Does it look good?
And my mind go,
mom,
are you really asking me if my penis,
let's just whip it out.
It's over the phone.
It was on the phone,
but I guess that's just say,
just say you made it,
you want some,
I think it's it.
It really is.
There's reasons why a lot of people should have it.
Like some people have way too much.
Again,
that's a cute thought.
I definitely have heard that there's not,
there's no medical reasons.
The India,
there's hope prevents aids.
Shut up.
Say Yeah,
I've heard sanitary.
Get out of here.
It's a natural.
You're supposed to have a sports can over your dick at some weird custom we do.
We cut it off as rude.
Shit's ridiculous.
Yeah,
you are supposed to have tonsils,
but the only time I take him out as when they break bro.
You don't take your tonsils out there working.
Awesome.
You're forced gins working fine.
Especially for skin to a tonsil.
Why did I do,
how about your appendix bro?
You don't fucking need up Bro.
You have your appendix out.
I don't know.
Would it bursts you take it out.
There's no reason to cut your fucking healthy normal.
All the old,
they used to always be fine,
but it's like tonsils were five,
two and the oldest people they died.
Yeah,
there wasn't fun.
It was a big difference there.
Just cause of death by a thousand years ago has nothing to do with what we know
now about anything.
Well,
I wonder why they started it in the first place.
What do you mean?
What do you think made them choose?
Do it's just the commandment,
but I don't know why non Jews do it.
It's gotta be from my mind.
You know why Jews do it?
But you don't know why they started doing it.
Whose idea was it?
Why did that stick?
It's not,
I don't think it's just because everyone does.
I think there's actually health reasons to do.
It's what my mom has explained.
Cause I said the same thing.
I'm like,
why?
Why even do it?
It did take the first question.
That would be interesting if it was five years ago,
but what the world of Google it look it up.
Health benefits of circumcision.
Here we go.
That's a good point.
Yeah,
but that,
because I asked,
I called my mom,
it's like we'll leave the poor kid alone if it didn't take the first time.
Don't do it.
And she goes,
no,
the doctor said,
the doctor says you want it to do that
guard up Dick.
And I guess I could take off too little and too much.
So it's like you have a doctor that's pretty much going,
hey,
you're going to have a great sex life or you're going to hate your life.
Isn't that weird?
This is one of those divided issues and that we're going to find two completely
different schools of thought.
Let's see if it was divided,
wouldn't be like 90% of our 80% or whatever it is.
Are The people you
states are circumcised?
Yeah,
I think it probably still would be because people do what they always done.
If the tradition for a long time over a few lifetimes to circumcision,
you know,
it's really difficult to break that off.
When people started having children and grandmothers starts asking,
you know you're going to,
you know,
take the baby and give him a circumcised aren't like a diamonds and wedding
rings.
The new thing,
the new thing.
What do you mean isn't that,
isn't that just like a hundred years ago really?
Something like that was of the diamonds and wedding rings or like you're
supposed to spend a lot of money and so surprised.
I wouldn't be surprised,
man.
Now it's like everyone has to do it just because it's like become accepted.
Let's see.
Complications.
Let's read complications.
Complications ranging in from oh 0.6 to ope to 55% have been cited where having
it or not having it.
Yeah.
Of complications in uh,
having it more specific.
Estimates have included two to 10% and oh 0.2,
2.6% okay.
Of circuits.
I just like compounding commiseration completely different numbers.
This is Wikipedia.
This is just wonky.
Anyway.
Uh,
according to the American Medical Association,
blood loss and infection are the most common complications but most bleeding is
minor.
Kids be stopped by applying pressure.
The survey of circumcision complications by Kaplan in 1983 revealed that the
rate of bleeding complications with shown between oh 0.1% and 35%
I think it's more now is what the doctor was saying because of this new way that
they do it.
That's higher complications.
I heard that a lot more people are having problems with certain citizens they
used and they used to and it's because it's,
it's,
it's like,
I guess it's easier for the doctor where in the past it used to be you go to
like somebody that does it as living like a,
uh,
a Jew,
you know,
whatever those guys are called.
It's all about the,
yeah.
But that guy,
that's all he does all day long.
Like he is like an artist for penis circumcisions.
Now they go to these doctors where they're fresh out of college and this could
be their second time doing it ever.
You know what I mean?
Is kicking the do it while the kids awake,
right?
Yeah.
So they made it what I believe it is,
they may it those keys the
kid under right.
Pinky and wine and let the kids suck on it.
That's just to get him drunk.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And then they'll
get the draw.
That's crazy.
Your job is what they actually do.
Raise a little drug that though fucking with baby gets a little harder before I
suck the kids penis after cutting it off.
I like to get him drunk.
My rival the Christian soon for weird pedophilia.
Shit.
Who was the first,
I want to know what the fucking origin of search from circumcision was.
I want to know what the fuck where did king from,
we should get a penis doctor in here.
I don't know.
I wonder if they know.
I wonder if there's some makes ancient cave art of here's The pyramid is good.
When Jews said to circumcise your children,
I don't think that was the new thing.
Like circumcision was probably already out.
Yeah.
Cause then decide what to do.
What the fuck caused it.
Sexually transmitted diseases wasn't around would be the house and years ago,
a thousand years maybe the clap and stuff like that shit is always been around
man.
It's got to been around,
you know,
um,
Al Capone died of syphilis.
Yeah,
that was,
but that wasn't,
yeah,
but what was that?
That was the 1930s it was at the time.
Two years ago.
Come on man.
This shit was around before that.
It was,
it's been around.
I bet it's been around a long time.
AIDS was around 50 years ago maybe.
I mean I,
I've worked,
got talking again,
they're saying that it might help prevent HIV infection.
I could see that totally more skin opening area where they have,
we've I to have a way higher rate of catching HIV than men.
201 200 times more likely to get HIV from a man and vice versa
because of all that open wound d looking area.
They can get all funky in there with east infections and they have to carry the
children.
It's a lot of guns.
A child would might make him way more likely to get aids.
Yeah.
So that's the rest of your taking that way.
Complications include and just having it,
having a clean house,
you know,
like fucking fungus and bug.
Do you have to Joey Diaz has no problems.
That's top of it and I've seen it in fucking five years.
He doesn't know we're strong.
After he had a heart attack.
It's hard,
strong seat at five years.
Well,
she sees him when he stands in front of the mirror.
I'm sure he gives it a little look over.
Was reading glasses on and you know another question I asked my mom is like,
why is my doctor talking to you about how good he is at cutting penises?
Is that like some kind of hit like he's hitting on my mom to at circumcision.
You know why?
It's because all my life as it's a pretty dick.
Just we'll show you.
What song
do you think about your mom hooking up with other dudes?
I asked my mom wants,
oh,
you're a mom single.
She,
no,
she's married but she was single for a while when I was like from third grade to
like,
I don't know,
seventh grade or sixth grade.
She went on,
she dated a guy that owned a house boat for a while named Denny that he's taking
on the boat.
Take me on the boat with his little hound dog.
That's a weird,
when your mom was told you guys yet.
Oof.
The worst one was is that my mom used to date this guy that was a pilot and he
just got his license and like he used to have this one that's a little small
propeller planes like three seater and we used to fly back and forth from like
different go to go places and I just remember going on like like six hour
journeys in this plane as a kid terrified out of my mind.
You know what they're like flirting in the front.
I'm the back of trying to re Garfield when take you up in a little baby plane
for six hours.
Yeah,
we would go on trips like go from like Ohio to like fucking West Virginia or
some dude's at rocket like that.
They have like a little propeller plane and they just fly out of here.
How fast can those jammies go?
I don't know but it's not like a jet fast but is it like 150 miles an hour fast?
Like a Cessna.
How fast you get a sense of how fast you're going to marry as fuck.
And I remember going through a storm once we went through a storm ones and I
remember thinking it was like airplane cause I was one of my favorite movies as
a kid who's an airplane.
I remember thinking that the whole time.
Like it's just like the movie airplane.
I'm going to dive into the episode of silver spoons where they all go down in a
propeller plane through a storm where they crush on a desert island.
I don't remember that one.
Rick.
He's got a bag of skittles or M and.
M's,
I don't remember now,
but he had to share with everybody why assessment can travel up.
The Cessna four oh six can travel up to the speed of 283 miles an hour.
Wow.
This was a lot more of the way.
Well yeah it is.
This was like a barnstorming plane.
Now this was the take assessment as a jet,
right,
isn't it?
It's like a fucking propeller plane rides it.
This was like one propeller in the front kind of plain and this is scary
planning like somebody to have like pull it down,
pull it off.
This is like how the fuck why?
And then my in this plane,
maybe that's a dope ass Cessna,
you know,
cause I've heard something about 150 or 200 miles an hour and that's how that
sounds pretty fast.
But either way,
that's pretty cool that you could do that and have that kind of freedom.
You can get your own plane and fly to another state.
It was pretty bad ass.
Avoid everything.
Avoid traffic,
avoid everything.
Just land.
There was a um,
Stephen King movie and I read the book first and then I,
then I got the movie,
there was a book,
I think it was one of his short stories,
but it's called night flyer and it was about a dude who was a,
he was a newspaper reporter.
Yeah,
yeah,
I remember that was terribly good book of short stories.
The movies terribly,
awfully great.
Yeah,
he's just one of those.
I was like,
it's bad,
but it's good.
Like a,
it's,
it's one of those movies where I'm happy if it's one o'clock in the morning and
I'm flipping through the channels board and then it comes on,
I'm like,
Oh shit,
this is,
well let me get some popcorn,
you know?
And um,
anyway,
in this story,
this guy was,
he had his Cessna and he would fly in to these little airports and there was a
vampire that was doing the same thing.
It's a vampire was flying in the vampire hunter an airplane and we'd like Jack
People at airports and shit.
Really?
Yeah.
They had like little tiny airports.
It was Kinda cool.
It's Kinda cool and Shitty at the same time.
It was not,
it wasn't,
you know,
anything to be proud of,
but it was fun.
It was fun to watch all of his stuff works better as stories.
Really.
Yeah.
Way better when you start making it a physical reality,
like,
oh,
it's hard.
Salem's lot pulled it off sales.
That was terrible.
I didn't think it was terrible.
We were young.
Maybe it was terrible.
I haven't seen it recently.
Random cares just popped up out of nowhere saying really important information.
But like,
who is that?
I enjoyed the fuck out of it when I was a little kid when I was dancing in front
of the window,
the maximum overdrive.
I think maybe he just,
Stephen King's never really gotten like probably a really good screenwriter and
director behind him except like stories are fantastical.
If there's a word,
you know he's,
his stories are so much better in the imagination,
you know,
some of them like,
like to Tommy knockers.
Did you ever see the movie the Tommy knockers that was not moving?
I saw Carrie remember it.
It was my Monday.
Have you seen that one?
But like there was a bunch of them that I've seen,
but I don't know if I saw a time,
you're not going to have a few seem to remember.
It was like a made for TV special.
The good,
but the book,
it's Great.
The book is really interesting,
man.
Like look like pet cemetery,
the movies.
Like it's all right.
It's okay.
It's not bad.
It's kind of interesting that I pay with Naama and I want to play with you.
Play with you daddy.
Whoa,
hang.
Maximum overdrive.
But the book is the shit man.
Pet Cemetery.
The book is fascinating.
Stephen King is so good at like pulling it raw emotions like these people that
wanted their daughter back.
So they buried her.
The whole thing about,
it's like,
cause with desperation then they had the cat,
the cat that came back that was acting all fucked up.
And we just fucking movies,
just books rather.
Oh the movies can never fuck with those books because you'd be alone in your
room when you didn't want to stop reading.
And you would keep going and going.
You know,
like I would read them like when I was on the train,
when I was headed into a,
when I was living in Newton,
I'd take the train into taekwondo in Boston and I didn't want to get off the
train man.
I'd get on a good one.
And I'd be like,
fuck,
I can't believe my stops here already.
Uh,
Christine Woods and Christine hemp.
That was one of my fears.
Christine.
And I liked the car ones.
For some reason.
Christine was awesome.
It was the car while,
yeah,
maximum overdrive kind of rode that one.
Maximum overdrive was the truck one where the truck's Green Goblin,
the one had the green Goblin as the f in the front of it and his bad out.
I just remember the Green Goblin and I thought that was,
is there any one God's responsible for more Badass fucking stories and Stephen
King,
it has got a lot.
It's very,
very,
he writes a lot.
So prolific sketcher he's doing an interview and even the whole time he's doing
interview might have been Dana Carvey.
It's one of those time periods and he's just typing away,
just typing away on his computer.
He's like,
yeah,
I'm writing a new book about uh,
whatever.
Like how do you get your,
um,
whatever.
He said,
ah,
you know,
I go to the supermarket and just keep typing.
And then officer,
they just stops and the guy goes,
what's the matter?
He goes,
I just,
she's got writer's block and back up top and then just goes right back to
typing.
Yeah.
It's funny.
No one's got less writer's block than that guy.
He just forces himself to work and work every day.
I mean,
he was working after he recovered from his horrible car accident.
If you don't know the stories,
some guy was like talking to his dog and his car and not paying attention.
He clips Stephen King.
It was walking on the side of the road.
Yeah.
Nailed them,
sent them him flying,
broke every fucking bone in his body,
his hips,
his legs,
his femurs arms,
his ribs.
He's just fucked for like the longest time.
So it took him forever to recover from that.
And as he's recovering and he set up a fucking death for him and gave him a
fucking cool
typing away.
I started working again.
You know Ralph,
he told the story at my a story show about how he got into a car accident.
Same thing I would think happened.
Really broke all the bones in his body.
They told him we're going to walk again.
When was this?
When he was,
I think in high school.
Really?
Yeah.
And then he was like a jock and then he said he was talking about,
but it's like he's just got real solid.
And he goes,
you know,
and then I gained some weight from there and just kinda spiraled.
Wow.
Shit happens in life.
And it was good cause
it really,
everyone was just listening hard.
Wow.
Yeah.
Ralph,
he's got that thing where you don't talk about it when you're around them.
But you know,
he's morbidly obese.
He makes jokes about it,
but I still don't really talk about it with him.
Yeah.
I don't either.
It's like there's a few of those dudes.
It's like you don't know what to say to him.
There's nothing he could say.
You got your own personal journey.
You're on man.
Yeah.
And you're not in a good spot.
You got to figure it out and you got to,
you got to somehow or another turn that boat or you junk.
Some people were don't be,
you don't need everything in your life.
Yeah.
And you know,
for some people it's so fucking difficult to lose weight.
Some people just haven't made,
they can eat all day and they don't have any problems at all.
It's hard.
Other people,
man,
like Brian,
you fucking struggle,
man.
Like you eat like a cheeseburger and all of a sudden you gain like five pounds.
Like it doesn't even make sense.
A cheeseburger doesn't even weigh five pounds.
Right?
Somehow or another,
like you gained more weight than you eat.
It's all because my metabolism
I like today,
I haven't had one thing today and it's five 30,
you know,
I haven't ate one thing today except coffee.
Well that's not good for your metabolism.
Terrible supposed to saying my metabolism is fucked up.
So I eat a hamburger.
Evolve meals going,
supposed to do it.
That's why I know,
that's what I'm saying.
That's why I suck at it.
Oh,
not eating habits we did for a while,
man.
You,
you,
you got down,
you've lost like some stupid amount of weight.
Didn't you?
60,
60 to 70 or you did it over the course of like five months,
right?
Well,
the main majority of is three months and then 10.
Wow.
How much of a gain back?
Uh,
I got down to one 65.
Right now I'm on 85,
so,
okay,
that's 20 pounds,
but not terrible.
But what's,
what 65 you were done or you're still losing weight?
One 65 like that.
That must be why,
but no,
I thought I looked like I had aids so I was like this,
that's what you look like.
Stupid.
I don't like the,
to me and that's just your faces.
You just get used to that round.
It's like whenever I shave a goatee,
but I have a good team for like a year later
shave,
but it's like,
Whoa,
what happened to my lips?
Yeah.
When I shaved my face,
I'm amazed at how small my head looks when I grow a beard.
My head looks like it's 10 times bigger,
just fucking black mass and my face,
her and I feel like I have this big fat,
stupid face.
My face feels fat and stupid and then I shave it and I'm like,
oh,
it's my head and my face was under there.
Yeah,
I just shaved it for that very reason.
I was just like,
God,
I look fucking old.
And fat right now.
Yeah.
I shaved it and I got id for fucking buying Nyquil the other day at fucking cvs.
You always get a deed for buying.
Never had that problem.
They're supposed to.
You get the idea,
no matter how old you are,
and so that they know who's buying it.
Oh yeah,
you can't.
It's not because it does cause your heart to you,
bro.
Bro,
that's not what they're doing,
man.
They're,
they're doing that
cause you're,
you know,
you're supposed to get registered.
You're supposed to register when you buy anything,
they can turn into math.
Wow.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
I love those moments in life.
You're convinced.
It was like,
well,
I guess I look really young.
I just have that convinced that this is a fact that this guy,
then you'll find it.
In another fact,
you're like,
oh,
just because of that girl to Vegas go,
oh my God,
I still get carded all the time and I swear to God,
she looked like she was 45 years old.
It was like,
some people just want to believe that I get carted all the time.
No one wants to ever admit like Dan remembering my shit.
I thought they took the chemical out of Nyquil that you can make math with.
Yes.
They took the chemical out of most things that you can make math with that you
can,
you can still do it because we could still make a certain amount of things.
The late seed aminophylline and there's,
there's certain,
there's certain things that are very desirable in there.
The codene used to be in Nyquil.
Right.
That was a different thing.
That's not the math stuff
the lady said,
cause when I asked her,
I was like,
are you seriously?
I Ding me for Nyquil?
She goes,
well,
it's because cvs has policy is to try to get kids not to get addicted to cough
syrup at a young age.
And that's why they have to do it.
Well there's that too.
And they said they ID anyone under the age of 18 or,
oh,
so she did idea for your age?
Yes.
Wow.
But what,
what kind of Shit are you getting?
You're getting prescription shit.
No,
it's just getting NYQUIL.
What was the other day?
Cough.
Nyquil doesn't have coding.
So if I sat a 16 year old boy and to get Nyquil,
they wouldn't sell to them.
Right.
This is a new thing at first cvs.
Why wouldn't know?
Because I've never gone to it.
I thought they were just,
I thought you were.
When I say Nyquil,
I don't buy like the drink.
I get like the,
the pills with couple pills like dayquil and nyquil that can't be tracked
through the other stuff.
Yeah,
I have.
I've seen it too,
but everyone,
they stopped having,
Cody knew and I stopped buying it.
I had it,
I was sick dude.
I was on news radio and uh,
I had the day off luckily and I was sick and I took coding that took Cody Nyquil
and I sat in front of my fucking TV watching TV going,
I feel so awesome.
I was so high.
Most mostly the coding is a very different kind of high,
it's a very like happy,
silly relax.
Like my pillow felt great,
like covers felt great.
Awe.
Nyquil with coding was the shit.
How much would you have to drink to get the,
I checked whatever that said to drink like a capsule at Benji's had a July 5th
party last year.
Every borough where he had his grandmother's cough medicine and some kids were
doing it.
The real shit with Cody was like the real crazy stuff.
Well the real shit with coding and it's hard to get but used to be able to get
it at a corner store.
I know a comic,
he used to be addicted to it.
I think it's just over the counter.
I think it could still get it if you just talk to a pharmacist at cvs
coding bro.
I don't think so.
I don't know if it's the same stuff bro.
I think
you can still get liquid night and they'll still fuck you up but it won't fuck
you up as well.
I think the Nyquil,
listen we were talking about
password guessing all day.
Actually look 60 to
maybe,
but yet,
you know when I was a kid I didn't even do the Nyquil for awhile but I started
off with doing is the no nos cause that was like speed and so I'd buy a Shitload
of Nodoz
peppers,
20 of those mother fuckers.
I was always scared of that shit.
Yeah,
I knew whenever 20 cause one of those things
you take it man,
you're committed to that
for the next fucking three hours.
That was my first,
my first job.
At least do that before a,
before a football and basketball games to get up,
you know.
So I take one of those pills.
Caffeine pills,
whatever they're called.
Yeah.
Now he'd f five I or five hour energy drink,
which I,
by the way,
I finally read the bottle.
It says half a bottle for moderate awakeness.
I've always took the whole thing and be up for like nine hours.
Yeah.
Now just take like a third really.
So it was enough for me.
I don't drink coffee like you do.
All right.
Yeah.
You don't drink any caffeine,
you a used to,
but then you got the headaches.
Once.
Right.
And you fail it.
No,
I never drank coffee coats to sprites.
Just my tastes changed one day and then the withdrawal gave me a humongous
headaches,
which were control is.
So then I was like,
I don't want to have to go through withdrawal it.
I changed my tastes.
I agree.
But coffee's awesome.
Awesome.
You guys are addicts.
Tait Fletcher said it best.
He said it's like a warm hug.
So coffee's like hug Tate.
He's right.
Yeah.
Coffee's delicious.
I love it.
I love it when I write.
It's comforting like a write something and then take a little sip.
Here's my little reward for writing.
Even as a kid,
I liked coffee,
ice cream.
Well I buy the shit I buys from Hawaii.
I buy that Kona coffee and it's so delicious,
man.
These their,
their bad motherfuckers.
It's weird how there's like spots in the world where they just have it down.
They can just grow one thing.
Awesome.
And in Kona on the big island of Hawaii,
they'd make the best tasting coffee man.
It's so good.
It's like a cigars from Cuba.
There's like a bolt of VA whole,
I forget the name of the place.
Perfect for smell area.
That's the area where they can grow the best cigars and Cuba is very small,
but that fucking soil,
there's something about that shit where the sun hits it every day,
whatever it is,
man.
The right spot on the planet,
the right amount of dead plants if rotted in there over the millions of years
and it's just the perfect soil,
the best tobacco,
and they've been growing them there for years and years like they can make a
real good cigar.
When they take the seeds from Cuba and they bring them to Nicaragua or Dominican
Republic,
they can still make a pretty kick ass cigar,
but there's just something,
a little extra kick.
If you know cigars,
it's a little extra kick about those Cubans.
Habanero peppers,
he take it get in from Mexico or hotter,
really hot.
When I was growing up here.
How much harder I can taste them.
Really?
Yeah.
You fucked up.
We never went to that Chili place died.
I always thought it would go,
fuck we fucked up man.
We talked,
there was a place in Encino called Chili,
my soul and I went there with my boy,
Tom Hirsch,
cocoa and David Hurwitz for fear factor and a,
it was a guy who was just a chili fanatic and he was the hard core.
Like you couldn't believe that a guy had a store and he was selling Chili this
hot because he would have a bunch of different levels,
but there was level.
I didn't even try 10 I tried level nine and that was good.
Okay.
Oh my God.
Wow.
It was that,
what's that called?
Called capisce couple.
What does that stuff called?
Capsaicin.
I've only seen it written.
I've never said the,
but that stuff.
He had that stuff in it and it had um,
the ghost pepper.
Yes.
That's what's called the ghost pepper,
which is just one of those gas.
He had the extract of ghost pepper in some of his shit.
Yeah,
I saw that at a hot place in Austin place.
It's sort of hot sauce bottles,
just Scoville units are off the charts.
So I didn't even have the super crazy death shit.
I had one notch below that.
I put one scoop into my mouth.
My tongue went numb.
I started hiccupping completely uncontrollably.
Tears were flowing down.
My face snot was pouring down my nose.
Now you can see how that's a defense mechanism.
Yeah,
planet.
Oh my God.
Never try that again.
If you accidentally like,
maybe I'll try this berry.
You would never try that barrier again,
but he told me that he would get dudes that would come in from Tibet,
especially when people heard about it.
I Tibet and dude's apparently have insane tolerance for hot foods and they would
come in and take his death shit and poor more death sauce,
more capsaicin,
capsaicin,
pour that shit on his chili and he couldn't believe they could eat it.
He would sit there watching him and these guys would just love it.
They were sweating and loving it,
loving it.
It's like I guess different people in different climates develop some sort of a
different tolerance.
A lot of time
I just shit blood now.
If that going to get close to that shit,
dude,
I'm telling you,
I have never had anything as hot as this Chili.
And this was like I said,
this is number nine out of 10.
Done.
He close.
Yeah,
he died.
He was a big,
it was a big guy.
He had a lot of his own Chili.
They used to have it too at that place.
The griddle,
is that the place they used to have his chili's?
These are seldom there.
Oh really?
That's how I found out the guy died because they've said,
hey,
you guys don't have those chilies anymore and the gall,
the guy died.
I'm like,
oh,
such a bummer man.
See that's when those people die.
Like a macho man,
Randy Savage.
Dot.
It's like,
it's too bad.
But he had,
he wasn't in my world anymore.
He wasn't assisting me or Michael Jackson.
He's not making any good music anymore.
But like when that guy like that dies,
you're like,
I,
you have a loss now.
Yeah.
Well he was a real chilly kind of sore.
I would've loved to seen him on that.
Uh,
Anthony Bourdain show,
the no reservation show would go,
he would attack.
Definitely had to visited that guy if the guy stayed alive.
But anyway,
his Chili's where the shit and he had like all these different flavors and they
were just,
all of them would just,
you'd be sweating and he had like these hardcore dudes that would go there.
Like he had like recommendations and all these articles written about his place
all over the wall.
And it was just gives,
it was the chili was so hardcore,
they,
you know,
like all the crazy people would be like to would we found the spot,
like if you're really insane into that hot food,
some people can just throw it down.
I love it.
I do too.
I do too,
but I don't think I could take as much as you could take and then you
way worse,
whereas way more than me.
Really?
Yeah.
It's also,
it's a stupid thing people brag about.
Yeah,
I can do this.
Like coffee,
just like that stuff better.
So manly thing,
how much you can take.
That's what that's told you.
The same thing.
People in Australia are making fun of me cause I wasn't drinking so much like oh
you have no tolerance and it was like light up a joint and I will take whole
country on
let's do this while I'm talking about manhood.
Let's fucking do this.
That's totally unfair because they don't have real partner.
No they don't.
I mean they do but they don't.
They think they do.
They think their pods awesome.
You're like that's cute.
You want to like rub their head?
Me Suite.
Yeah.
Sweet.
We do a little 15% THC.
Joey Diaz brought some shit over yesterday.
It was 34% THC.
The mats.
Is that what he brought?
Oh Gee Kush.
That's ridiculous.
That shit can change the world.
Okay.
If we get enough people to try Matt,
Oh Gee Kush.
It could change the fucking attention for the whole ride to he takes you for the
whole ride and when you're done you have some things to think about.
You have to like,
oh yeah,
you got some things to think about it.
There might be somebody you want to call up and apologize for some shit that
happened to the seventh grade.
Just tell us more.
Yesterday had the stuff he grows his logic Kush from the same clone is the guy
grabs his store and he built the little bugs are too small.
They boiled down and make honey butter out of it.
Do you guys ever seen that?
Oh my God.
They sift it through butane that the beauty,
so it melted.
It's like paste that the butane Bernoff cause it just evaporates in the air.
Um,
and then it's just this like paste so brutally.
Hi.
Oh my God,
I'm so scared.
Just listening to you talking about that now.
I think he's had half grams go for like 60 people don't even know that have
never eaten it.
They really don't know.
And that don't people especially squares or if people really straight,
they don't know that experience.
How Tara,
when we joke around about it,
like when Joey pulled out that cookie yesterday,
I got scared.
I was,
yeah,
I got that taste in my mouth.
After you eat mushrooms right before you start shipping.
That's the taste.
There's a smell that certain really powerful edibles have.
There's the smell on the air on the airline to a yes.
Yeah.
Those are from the same place he gets it from.
Oh No.
There was nothing on the airline.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
You didn't do that.
There's no way you would do something that ridiculous me.
It's just a story.
It's fiction anyway.
Yeah,
there's a smell.
You opened up that cart and I was like,
what?
Going to expect the smell like smell.
Especially in that too,
but that plane broke that Tupperware seal and that hit me.
I was like,
I always thinking I was thinking things ran through my mugshot,
mugshot,
stamping the hand stamping the hand fingerprints,
cuffs,
jail door shot phone called a lawyer.
Shit.
How much motherfucker,
I gotta be here for how long?
Goddammit.
Ari slapping arc
flashes.
I have like a slide show presence.
Are you ever like have a friend like curses and public ucls kids behind her?
He just forgot what it was.
That was that feeling.
The same thing too.
I was like,
oh my God,
first of all that,
but you just brought so much,
there was no way you could eat it all.
And I was like,
it was for than trip.
We were too deep and too,
there was only a couple hours to land.
I'm like,
I can't do it.
This last time you want to do is be baked to the gills and then go through
foreign
country costumes.
Talked to him.
I didn't take a man.
Yeah Dude.
I,
well I show up for planes high,
but I don't bring anything on me.
But when we were in Australia,
I ate a cookie right before we left for the airport.
So by the time we got for the airport,
I'm,
I'm giving this lady my passport and she's telling me that it doesn't look
anything like me.
You're believing her.
She's just some
dumb,
dumb.
I was like,
it was one of those things where were talking to somebody like,
I can't believe I'm forced to have a conversation with you and you're in some
sort of position of power,
you know?
I go,
that's amazing.
She goes,
doesn't look anything like you.
I go,
what the,
what are you talking about?
I go,
that's me.
I'm smiling in that page.
See that's me.
I got a big smile.
It's just like she's sick.
She had like,
why are you shaking your heads cause this isn't me.
Like what are you saying?
I got it like ambivalent,
like this is ridiculous.
She do.
She was questioning me.
I was like,
oh my God lady.
I've been here for three days.
I worked for the ultimate fighting championship.
I'm going,
Oh wow,
the fuck.
Oh Wow.
Crazy Australian broad.
They're all crazy.
Oh they are.
But at least you know they let Canada and Canada like,
no,
you cut a fart in high school.
You did anything fucked up.
Even if what you did was like exonerate,
you were exonerated from,
you're still getting pulled into a room.
Eddie Bravo can't go to Canada without getting pulled into a room because he got
a gun charge that was legal.
He had a gun on him.
He was legally,
he's working for a check cashing company,
carrying around a ton of cash with them.
He got pulled over for a traffic violation and he informed the officer,
I have a go a loaded gun in the car.
Sit.
Thank you.
Step out.
Why do you need this?
They,
they handcuff him.
They put him in the car.
I worked for check cashing company.
Um,
I have to carry a gun and carry large amounts of cash.
They check up at the store.
Okay,
you're all set.
Here's your gun.
Free to go.
But it's still on his record.
So every time we go to Canada,
he gets pulled over into a fucking room and they grill him.
That's nuts.
Yeah.
They don't fuck around.
And Canada son,
what are you doing?
He went shrines in another place.
Brian.
Strange.
Brian today probably.
Why I you to show for it as well.
To be a part of it.
I'm a scanner.
I just ate.
There's no reason I need to reset my body before I go back and see that.
Yeah,
it's good to take time off,
bro.
You learned something.
You had a crazy trip and everybody who says that you don't learn anything and
it's just like,
fuck you.
I start.
I'm so tired of that argument,
man.
It's online all the time.
Like,
you know,
what were you thinking?
Just frying your brain.
You are definitely haven't done it.
Here's what I think.
I don't feel that there's a connection to a higher power.
I thought that,
but I learned stuff about myself and what was going to be happy.
I see myself and my place in the world clearly,
right and the most,
the more that I could hold onto and take back with me,
the better it is for me.
Well,
the idea is that that is the higher power.
The higher power is realization.
The higher power is understanding.
The higher power is a stage of enlightenment that you can achieve while under
the spell of the mushroom that you don't normally have.
Oh God.
It's a higher,
we're going deeper and deeper connects you more and more to the truth and more
and more to the love and that what you're getting out of it by getting a fresh
perspective on yourself and dissolving your ego and you know,
you feel this,
the connection of love and everything.
W W what it's supposed to be is you connecting to the Gaia,
to mother earth,
to the true love of the universe and then coming back to reality and have
something to sort of learn from and have something to sort of like,
you know,
look at your life.
That is the idea of her sitting in my car and thinking there's no reason.
I don't tell people like other comedians will say that I like something to do,
just show my support instead of keeping it quiet and only say,
yeah,
this is messed up.
Just tell.
I remember writing a letter to Chris Fairbanks saying you have a really
interesting delivery style and it's cool that it works like that.
It's like technically that's awesome.
That's cool.
You just said thank you.
I really appreciate that and that's,
that's like why wouldn't I be doing that?
Why would I be at holding myself back from doing that shit for so long?
Yeah.
I love when you know you're not supposed to say it,
but I love when I get emails from like comics that I respect and I say they saw
something.
It's like,
you know,
like if Stan Hope,
we'll say send me some email.
And he saw something that I didn't love it and I'm like,
wow,
it sits a nice feeling.
And I do it all the time.
I really had me going.
I do that all the time,
especially in person.
I love to do that in person.
You See Guy Light Up,
you know?
And you tell him like,
God damn,
that bit you did was awesome.
Right off you get off.
Yeah,
I remember that by the way.
Yes you are after that.
But I've got to,
well,
even when they,
I mean whenever you tell them it doesn't matter,
just tell him.
Yeah man.
You know it's,
it's all hippy bullshit.
Everybody,
you know who'd be bullshit spreading all that.
Love you.
Queers go soldiers.
Doug's was the way to do talk that way.
If you have that,
why are you so unhappy?
So I'll be unhappy.
There's a lot of dudes are insecure,
they're insecure and they're struggling and they don't have what they want.
And when you're in a state where you don't have what you want and you haven't
achieved what you want,
you're in this constant state of unease.
And when you see people who are at ease,
there's a tendency,
a natural tendency that I've,
I've,
I've experienced myself to shit on those people to shit on these people and all
these fucking asshole what you think cause you fucking,
you got some money,
you're better than me.
You know the,
there's a tendency to like,
oh yeah,
you're a fucking materialists.
You have great,
like your real deep,
yeah.
There's important things in life other than you know your career or your life
and they want to say this just because they,
they're in a position of unease.
It's like hitting a,
the Kardashians.
Yeah.
It's hard to like anything man.
It's all,
a lot of people have a hard time liking things.
Yeah.
They have a hard time enjoying things because they don't like themselves.
Even if you're not until gravity,
you can like lots of stuff and we'd be like,
that was awesome that it's,
some pitcher can be terrible but could throw one good picture.
The game get lit up a 14 rods,
but one fucking beautiful pitch.
You could appreciate that one pitch.
I don't know what the fuck are you can,
you can see the positives and everything.
You don't have to everything just because they're more successful.
You don't have to hate them.
You know,
I deal with a lot of these message boards and especially for mixed martial arts
and disrespected these guys show to fighters and you know that are doing the
most dangerous and most fucked up job in the world.
The riskiest job outside of being a soldier or a cop or a fire percent.
Someone who actually risk their life.
The next riskiest job is probably being a mixed martial arts fighter.
It's,
there's very little chance you're going to have a good future.
There's a real high chance you're going to get badly,
badly injured.
You may never make a lot of money.
Yeah,
you're going to have knee reconstructions.
Everybody has broken hands,
everybody has this always shit.
It's going to go along and if you do it right,
you can get glory and you can get to,
you know,
a great financial place and you can,
but it's risky as fuck.
And I think that people,
oh,
the people who are fans,
all those people who are out there doing it and trying it,
you owe them your respect.
Some level of respect.
When you see something a very high level,
a lot of times it's like,
well you know,
you say he didn't have a good style.
You say he didn't fight well it wasn't a good fight.
But to call them like these,
these,
these things that they say on these forums like that people,
they get so fucking salting of fighters and shit all over,
all their performances.
It's like,
man,
guys cancel each other.
Alec people are shitting all over.
Tiago Alvarez like Chicago was like,
Shit,
couldn't pull the trigger.
[inaudible] Rick story's a beast.
Man.
That kid's a gorilla.
That kid jumped all over.
Tiago need the fuck out of his legs,
didn't give him any inches,
any room.
Instead of saying Taco sucks,
how good is that restoring?
And it was a good stories a boy.
And can you just hold on?
So he's putting me to sleep.
You're crazy.
It's,
they're balancing themselves out because both guys are awesome as fuck.
They're canceling each other out rather cause Tiago,
Elvis is awesome.
He's a bad motherfucker.
And this Rick story's a bad motherfucker too.
And when you put the two of them together,
sometimes it's,
it takes a long time for something to happen because they're defending and
canceling each other out and they're throwing bombs at each other and both of
them or cover up well covering up.
Well,
you know,
it's,
they're well matched when they're well matched.
It makes for a really difficult fight for one guy to get the upper hand.
So people get so disrespectful.
And so like unappreciative of of the efforts of what these fucking guys go
through,
they did it.
We can't even wrap our heads around what they have to do.
They dedicate like six,
eight weeks of their life,
a minimum training,
training all day,
every fucking day.
I say the training videos,
I'm like,
oh,
I never want to do any of that every day.
And just people probably are 11 years old.
You know,
some of them,
you get these people and you're like,
oh,
we forget you had a guy's private.
We know it's a lot sadder.
Some of them are in their forties there's still just a bunch of mean cunts.
Talking Shit about something like that online.
It's like,
yeah,
well I think people are learning how to navigate online.
I think there's,
there's more negativity than ever online,
but I think that's because there's more people online than ever.
There's places where you can find where you can minimize your negativity,
like your Twitter account.
You can easily minimize the negativity on your Twitter page,
like block.
And people are constantly do that.
I very,
very rarely will argue with anyone on Twitter and I just,
when you say something Conti,
what am I gonna defend myself?
I just block you or I retweet what you said so
that everybody else knows what kind of a con you are loving.
And I block you.
If if they say something where they're just questioning something,
I thought that it,
that's okay.
Just say it nicely,
but when you're like,
you fucking idiot moron.
It's like,
shut up.
I know there's so many videos like an NPR today on the way over here,
they were talking about this guy wrote some book about how the way you act
online will bleed into your real life.
Oh,
for sure.
If you're constantly like,
you fucking loser,
idiot,
kill yourself.
There's video's terrible.
Fuck you.
Like you take that with you to work the next day and you're more negative.
Not all of it,
but some level.
You and Wayne were negative with your coworkers and stuff and your friends
totally makes sense.
You know it's,
you can't just get away with that it,
there's this energy connected to all that negativity you're pumping out and it's
going to come back around again.
It sounds like hippie bullshit,
but it's proven to be reality 35 okay.
They have great lives.
They're stressful lives.
There'll be a hippie.
It's not the worst thing in the world.
New Challenge for you.
Hiring,
talking about every time you see a flower that you have to smell it.
Every time I see a flower that's going to be so hard.
That's ridiculous.
Or rose?
No,
I would still have to florists and every corner in La.
I've been doing it for like the last couple of months.
Yeah,
and it's so embarrassing the other days and dude was like skateboarding and I'm
like,
Oh fuck,
I'm walking by this.
Whereas I have to stop and smell this flower,
but there's this kid skateboarding coming towards me.
It's just stop.
It smelled like,
why are you forcing yourself to do it?
Whether you like it or not because it's good.
It's good.
It smells great.
It's good to tell yourself not to be embarrassed about the skateboard or just go
ahead and spell it if you want.
Sounds good.
Brian,
I'm bringing you a doctorate.
I'm convinced there's something really wrong with your major psychological
damage.
You're like,
uh,
I don't know.
There's something up there.
You don't.
You don't see anything awesome about stopping and smelling a flower every now
and then,
but don't let it fucking old Jeff.
Don't be late for work.
Make you miss your flight.
So many flows up to keep putting one.
No,
no.
I'm saying when you're walking,
if you walk by when smell one.
But it's great.
I,
I've been doing it for awhile and I love it now.
Fucking good shit.
Or you had a,
a freak out when you were at Brian's place.
Yeah.
Oh,
here's another,
because I did have a freak out.
I would say,
if you're going to do psychedelics,
make sure you are around people that you trust people that will help you.
Um,
don't want to put yourself in a bad environment.
Don't do it.
Live on a podcast when you're jammed into our room with five other people.
Probably either.
Maybe.
Yeah.
So the idea was you guys were going to,
you were going to do it on a podcast live.
You're going to do Salvia,
which is still legal,
right?
It's illegal in California.
So we weren't doing anything wrong folks.
So you decided to do,
isn't that crazy?
It's Salvia is legal by the way.
This shit.
Anyway,
so you're doing Salvia,
you're doing it live on the air and then you have a little spazz out.
The problem is here's the deal and I will say this,
I can't stress enough.
Really,
you need to trust your friends because I s I would watch Brian fuck with
everybody else.
It was doing,
it shall farts right in their face and tell the girl she had her boobs out and
make her feel self conscious and it's like fine,
don't stop doing that.
You don't like they're fucked up like acid and mushrooms and Salvia,
they don't need anybody's help.
Right.
Work.
They will work
on their own chemicals.
Right.
So every time he started pulling at me,
I knew he was fucking with me in some way.
But in my weird a world where I barely had a grasp on reality where I'm like,
no,
if you pull me over there,
that's where I'll die.
And I know you're not trying to pull me over there,
but I'm going to drown to death for the sake of your little game.
What?
Yep.
Cause you don't know where you are.
I have in a different planet where the rules of physics of the gravity and the
time and meanwhile Brian is pulling you through me and I think he's fucking with
her for first.
Let's,
let's,
let's rewind here.
We had two other people do it on this podcast,
which is the 90 shock probably guys and the first person we see hang.
And again,
I did not fuck with either of these people while they were doing,
you know,
after it,
after it was done and they came out of it,
we kind of fucked around but they were back into consciousness.
You shoved,
this is not one that fart spray,
um,
fleshlight into his face.
He was not,
he was shoved it out of your face while you were under two?
No.
All right.
That's another thing.
I didn't see it.
If you watch,
yeah,
if you watch the video,
it was behind his bag and it was only for the cameras.
It wasn't for our buck is hearing you say stuff like this so that it's like now
I'm always like,
are you guys fucking with me or is my reality changing it?
If I see something,
if I see,
let's say I did see that drapes becoming waterfall.
Right.
I want to know something's fucking with him.
Like I want to know.
That's probably not the case.
If he now watching this video,
you realized I wasn't fucking with you at all.
No,
you were just like mill.
It looks on the screen behind me.
All right.
The screen behind you was behind you so you couldn't even see it.
I could turn this far.
It's like you didn't,
but you were trying to do the same thing to Alison.
I saw you.
Fuck.
Sorry.
What I was doing was not that.
Alright.
What I was doing was not fucking with you.
It was Ford,
the video viewers of the show that the TV was behind you.
You couldn't even see the TV.
Yeah.
Uh,
okay.
Do you think that possibly misconstrued what you took us to the UFC before you
even start shipping?
He couldn't see when I was doing,
before I even start tripping people.
There's certain types of people and that's okay.
It's just who you are.
We'll like to do things like this,
which you did.
And Mike Bryan,
I know I'm not trying to get,
and you keep trying and I was like,
that's annoying.
Hey sooner I will cherry talk.
Brian,
you got to let them talk because you can't know exactly he's talking about
because you can't interrupt this.
This is Brian.
This site,
people listening,
right?
Container.
I don't want anyone to do that because soon I will be tripping and I want to
know,
oh,
that's me tripping.
I want to trust that I'm losing my reality now and not someone's fucking with me
and making me think.
What did we made?
Cycle Patty.
Thanks.
She was on something.
She didn't think she was on anything.
We make her think she was tripping or whatever it was.
We didn't fuck with her trip.
Okay.
All right.
This is what I told you last time.
You said this when we did,
uh,
when you're,
what you're talking about where I was talking like this.
All right.
This is two people having fine out at a UFC and you did acid and it's not me
fucking with you when I go,
oh,
are you fueling it?
It's me just joking around with you as a friend would do if we weren't even on
acid.
Right?
Right.
I'm not sitting here going,
I'm going to fucking ruin this trip.
Ooh Girl,
who you are so to you
haven't done anything wrong.
Do you understand how this is coming?
You're a test that you think,
well,
I'm not saying you did.
I have not said you did once,
but I'm saying you are so attached to that.
You are so defending it.
You can't say,
yeah,
maybe I shouldn't have been saying that.
If it was annoying to you while you were trying to like trip out on acid,
maybe it wasn't noisy.
I didn't mean to be,
but you're not listening.
What happened?
I know what happened when Alison was,
Alison was under and you kept or was there something weird and you kept saying,
Oh,
you had your boobs out.
You said it a few times.
Alison was,
Alison was an under,
you know that right?
She never point.
We never went under.
I know she didn't want another,
cause he was sitting there talking to us the whole time.
You so she faked it.
No,
she,
when you're in Salvia you either go under or you're feeling fucking crazy.
Right.
Already went to a different rural.
That's what Alison did it do.
I don't get what you're defending.
So she was going fucking crazy.
And you're telling her tits were out so that's okay.
No,
no.
We're all sitting in there talking to her back and forth.
She was making sense.
She was not out of her mind and we're talking about who later was that she was
still tripping out.
Balls
talk good when you're fucked up on psychedelics and still be fucked up though.
She knew where she was is what I'm saying.
She did not fall
because he knows that you're not going to Barf ever.
Like,
no,
you're not going to Barf.
And I was like,
it's a trip.
I was like,
I wouldn't sit right there if I were you.
But I was freaking out.
I felt like I was going to Barf and I was toppling over,
but I was still,
and he was telling me,
he was telling you,
you're not going to get barf.
Who'd got you a trashcan?
Who is doing all this stuff to you but you still think I attacked you somehow
when you did your salary?
Yeah.
And beforehand too.
I see you fucking with people.
That's okay.
And then,
and then when we did acid one time you thought I was fucking maybe and just
because I was like,
hey,
go you fucking with you.
But I had to fully tell you what somebody like Brian,
why do you always think I'm a fucking with you?
You'd like to do that.
That's just why is that in your head?
You think?
Well maybe we Brian,
Brian,
Brian.
Do you not understand that maybe the way you play around,
even though I know you're just playing around,
it might not be fun for other people.
Yes,
but if,
but what I'm saying is what he's talking about when he was doing acid,
we were walking at a UFC.
Ryan,
hold on,
hold on.
Hold on,
hold on,
hold on.
Hello.
You are explaining the reason why you did things and you are saying that you did
it just as a friend and you are completely discounting his experience with what
you were doing and that what you were doing was annoying to his response was
saying that you were doing it all from a good place,
a place of a friend,
a place of playing around so he shouldn't be upset.
But what he's saying is your what?
Your actions are directly making him feel like shit and you're not coming to
grips.
I see what you're saying.
But your officer,
did he hear what his response was?
Hey,
I'm not tripping.
And I was like,
oh no,
we're just fucking around.
We're walking to the bathroom.
He wasn't work.
I'm not sitting here making voices to Ari that's sitting there going,
wow,
I am fucked up.
We're walking to the bathroom at a UFC.
I understand Brian.
I know all I'm saying.
Okay.
What he said.
What?
Brian,
you have a real hard time with other people agreeing with you and
a bunch of different examples of you fucking with people.
All right.
What's another one,
Brian,
you don't feel bad for your actions,
man.
You don't feel bad for making some money.
You're making me feel bad about something that,
that that didn't exist.
We're walking to the bathroom both and he's not trying to make you feel bad
about that.
I'm making you feel about about defending it relentlessly.
The action itself was no big deal and it is a big deal to him.
He said that you were ignoring him,
you and relate to him and then when he was tripping you would knowing your
morning.
Okay,
got it.
But I've got it.
All right.
Was that the only thing I did that night?
Yes.
Right.
Oh,
I know later in the night I had to tell you like Brian,
what do they do?
Okay.
Later on then I had to tell me where I tell you,
Brian,
seriously,
I need your help right now.
I can't have you fucking with me.
I need you to be protective of me instead of fucking with I know,
but I wasn't doing anything when he said that.
You just said that when we're sitting there at the UFC,
do you remember that were on our way out?
Yeah,
we're towards the outside but I wasn't doing anything.
When you said that you were just telling me to not fuck with you,
right,
cause you were talking weird before.
No,
I wasn't.
Okay.
Anyway,
see Hong,
when you put the spark sprained his foes,
he wasn't.
He wasn't.
He was.
We found out later that he was hung up on it later,
that every time he gets to wait three minutes,
they were like still super bomb.
Now you couldn't have known that fine.
We all thought they were fine,
but you were fucking with them.
That's what you'd like to do.
You put that fart spray on people's faces like the read the in space or did he
open it up?
I don't remember.
You just shoved it right in his face.
It was only a second layer to it and I did.
I open it.
I'm going to see it.
You just open it up and shoved his face.
He didn't even talk.
There was no like smell out there and just,
I didn't remember that.
Okay.
It's all on there.
But with the Ari with that,
that whole thing,
that last time when,
when when I was talking funny and stuff like that,
that was not me fucking with you.
And I know,
I know you said that at that time,
but that really upset me because what we were doing,
we were just walking to go to the bathroom and we were conversating and I just
said our seats those one time we're sitting our seats and you're like,
no,
it was,
we were walking to the bathroom.
I was like,
Brian,
stop it.
Please integrate.
I'm not doing anything.
I'm like Brian or joking.
Yeah,
but it's like,
it was kind of ruining my truck.
But Ari,
you weren't tripping yet,
remember?
I know,
but you want to know what's,
no,
but I know,
I saw you sitting there tripping and it wasn't just 10 minutes after you took
acid and went and do that.
This is what I'm trying to tell you is it wasn't really attack.
I understand that,
but you did do it and it did it.
And when you lose your grasp on reality,
never talk in a weird voice.
Anytime you do any kind of real defensible
show,
do you understand what you attack?
RSS Feeds right now being attacked right now you're acting silly.
Okay.
No one's attacking you.
All right.
My point to the people out there was do not do,
I would not do mushrooms with someone who you might think would mess with you in
any way.
You look.
No one's saying that what you did do didn't come from a place of fun and
friendship and that you weren't trying to fuck with him.
But if someone does not want you to do that while you're doing it and you do it
and it bothers them and it freaks them out,
whatever you did to him,
I saw you grabbing him.
I saw the video when he was fucked up and you were holding onto him and talking
to them.
I saw you pull out the flashlight and I know you were just joking around,
but you can,
you not see that even though you're doing this as a friend and just playing
around for the video for him while he was tripping out,
that might not be comfortable.
That's what I'm saying.
You saw the video and you're still thinking I did something wrong in that video
chewed.
What is wrong with you?
I'm not saying you did something wrong.
I'm saying you were playing around and he might not have enjoyed it.
Is that okay?
That's you do things and other people don't enjoy them.
Can they not enjoy some things you do?
So I remember somebody once you like,
you're a lot of live video.
I was stuck on the telling everyone to shut up for saying don't talk about death
in,
I was fucking with them.
It didn't discount all the other shit you did.
And if video are,
he tried to stand up and I was the one that jumped to the ground to try to hold
him.
So he buried himself.
Thank you for that.
And then you start swinging and fam flailing and kicking and stay while everyone
was just watching.
I was trying to protect your legs and hand from night punching windows and
breaking things all around you.
I was in this place where I was coming back from another world,
right?
The Laws of physics that apply to me and I thought I was in grave danger and
here's this truckster who's grabbing me,
who doesn't understand?
I've been at my world.
I know I'm not saying that.
I'm not saying what you thought I'm saying is that Joe's saying that I've did
all this stuff to you but and I have no one did anything wrong.
You're not even listening to what I said.
I didn't see you do anything wrong.
I said,
well,
you did.
You did out of a place of friendship and playing around and doing it for a video
show and you didn't do anything wrong,
but it sometimes things that you do that are not wrong still annoy people and
out of it as a general courtesy.
You don't do those things because other people don't like you to do them.
To them.
It's that.
It's that simple.
It's not that you did anything wrong.
It's just some people don't like you doing some shit and they're in another
fucking dementia.
It's like it's August drugs.
Look,
it's like best case scenario.
You got a smile.
Worst case scenario,
you've ruined this trip,
which is not the most egregious crime ruined your trip.
You take the chance to,
that trip was ruined because of you because my lack of distrust with you,
the Salvia,
but oh,
anyone else have to still had a great time.
Don't make it what you saw.
There was not a bad time,
so you're bad.
Trip was all my fault.
Just the last part.
I was trying to get you specifically Brian red band off of me because you are
going to play a trick on me and put me into a really dangerous position that you
weren't aware of.
This is me.
I think talking about money,
no grasp on reality.
It's done well.
Obviously.
It's what it was like.
I don't want the trickster fucking with me right now.
It's very unfortunate that you had these feelings.
It's very unfortunate that Brian feels attacked here.
You know,
but I think that the [inaudible],
first of all,
the idea of doing this fucking crazy psychedelic drug on a podcast with a bunch
of Comedians,
it's ridiculous.
You can't get upset at Brian because here you are on a fucking,
the idea of what you're doing is silly beyond belief.
Guess who didn't do it?
Because I wouldn't do that.
I wouldn't put myself in that situation.
Well,
what I'm saying,
you keep thinking that I'm attacking you.
I don't think you did anything wrong.
I watched what you did.
I don't think you did anything wrong,
but you have to accept fact that even though you didn't do anything wrong,
you shouldn't do it.
If it freaks somebody out,
if it's fucking with someone's head in,
you know they're telling you to get the fuck off them.
Maybe you should get the fuck off them.
You got to leave him alone.
I know you weren't doing it.
The idea was ridiculous.
You should have never done it.
Well,
I mean,
but why not,
right?
Yeah,
but I'm saying it's not the perfect way to do Salvia and you're going to get
upset at some shit because Salvia such a mind blowing incredible reality
dissolving experience and the people are fucking with you and joking around with
you and there's a camera on you and the fucking Internet world is watching.
It's going to suck anyway,
man.
It's going to be fucked up there.
That world watching and I don't mind and it's still worth seriously what you
saw.
If you see that video,
that was a great trip.
I had a really good time next.
That was the other place I was there for months and years.
We're going to take you and we're going to put you in my fucking cage out in the
garage where you can't hurt yourself and then we're going to do,
we're going to Salvey you the fuck up and push you in that thing and lock it
down and then we're going to video tape so you can flail around and just going
to run in the heavy bags.
I'll be handcuffed under watering.
Just pool.
Yeah.
He'll be doing a David Blaine with one of those Chinese surgical masks on and it
just bugs me that Ra because I really didn't fuck with you and I didn't fuck
with you that,
that last thing,
the UFC,
I purposely did not fuck on you.
I think you were fucking with people,
but I think you were doing it for the right reasons,
but you want it to be funny to make money show if you're not talking right,
and just making those jokes.
It's like that's the joke comes from a place of,
wouldn't this be funny if I'm messing with Alison,
I can't speak for them,
but I bet you asked him both of them,
if I fuck with them or wearing their trip in any way,
they would say absolutely not.
Okay.
Doesn't remember you shoving a thing in his face.
That's fine.
But I saw you shove a fart spray thing and somebodies face while they were out
and I'm like,
oh,
that might happen to me when I'm out.
If this guy who likes doing that is around.
Yeah,
it's all Weldon.
Earlier than that,
I put the,
he didn't do anything wrong,
Brian,
you didn't do anything wrong.
You're doing a whole lot of this stuff.
Entertainment,
not fuck with people's trips out there.
Let them have their guests.
But if you're going to have a fucking trip on a comedy podcasts with a bunch of
comedians and they're all laughing and giggling,
guess what?
It's going to be wonky.
It's going to go nutty and I don't think you can blame the comedians for fucking
with you.
And especially when an ongoing gag is our flashlight wine and cheese prank.
Okay?
That said,
Brian,
you,
you fucking lock up in a field.
Like make people's brains say,
okay,
you lock up and you don't ever considered the possibility that maybe you
could've done something to annoy him.
You have to,
you will tell you this doesn't have to be logical.
If you annoy somebody,
sometimes you just annoy someone.
You don't mean to [inaudible] there was a time at sales once where somebody,
some girls might even share it with somebody.
She was like,
Oh,
we've got a lot of layers are on overload.
It's like three layers.
I'm like,
Brian,
it's not a bad thing if you have layers on and you're like,
oh,
but it was like no one's attacking.
You don't have like deny instantly.
I liked to wear layers.
This layer right here feel the same.
This is how,
this is not a commentary on the check for ovaries tonight.
Boy,
which doctor [inaudible] had a question for you cause I stopped doing a Swain
milk recently
because of all the estrogen and stuff like that.
I feel like a man again,
almond milk have the same problems that every day.
Make that go amongst real good.
It's easy to adjust.
It's very easy to agenda.
It's really good for babies.
Babies love it.
Um,
the uh,
almond milk is delicious.
I use that from my,
um,
my shakes every day.
But don't get the shit that's flavored cause it's just sugar.
It's this,
you know,
you get like a vanilla.
There's nothing healthy about that.
Absolutely.
Make your own almond milk.
I know some do to make their own shit.
Supposed to be much more delicious,
but it's a huge fucking pain in the ass.
Cause soy milk good for you.
So yes,
it's not bad for you,
but you can get,
soy is a tricky thing man.
And especially if you,
if you follow genetically modified food and soil,
a lot of times it's genetically and I wasn't trying to attack you.
You're always subject.
Just changed that one thing that one time when you said,
I always trying to route voices.
I knew I wasn't fucking with you because I knew you weren't tripping it.
I know,
but it's like that.
That was me just going cake.
You're about to do acid.
Very exciting doesn't it doesn't help anybody when the trips,
it's all good.
But I didn't mean to go times.
The correct answer sometimes is,
sorry I was fucking around.
I thought it was funny at the time.
Instead of like defending to the death what you've said.
My only thought was if I want to do,
you're a great guy,
but under these circumstances it's not perfect.
So if I'm going to have a nice [inaudible] Sam and everyone else was like going,
he looks dead and they're saying all these horrible things.
Now with the one guy that told him this time,
does it really matter what other people did?
Does it really matter if there's something
that you did that annoys him?
You have to take responsibility for that.
It's,
I'm not saying you did anything wrong,
man.
We've,
we've discussed this to death.
RSS Feeds a bra goal perhaps will be joining us in Vegas.
I might throw him on stage.
This motherfucker,
it needs to go up there with a huge place.
Yeah.
Arash is going to be there July 1st first.
I believe Benson is going to stop in and do a guest set too.
Oh,
nice.
Um,
so July 1st,
that's a,
in Vegas,
June 25th I'm with Cocoa Canary.
Joey Diaz,
the captain razor.
What does he put on his deck?
Drain on the deck and Ajax cut the right size car.
Anyway,
Carnegie Music Hall,
a Saturday,
Dave,
June 25th and that's in Plattsburgh.
Oh No,
it's not the New York.
It's big deal.
That's such a humongous difference.
I was like,
well I didn't hear about your play.
Carnegie Hall.
I know how many people fit in Carnegie Music Hall in New York.
I don't know.
I can't fill that thing,
but I think,
um,
didn't fucking Charlie Sheen fill that thing.
I need a scandal.
I don't want it.
Anyway,
Carnegie Music Hall in Philadelphia,
which is the day before the UFC and then there's another one,
like I said,
July 1st it'll be me and Ari and Joey Diaz and most likely these great,
the best place we played in Vegas.
We got to Dale the years.
That was the best place.
We did a lot of gigs at house of Blues and how's the blues?
They're the people that work there are really cool as fuck,
but the venue is too wonky and courts palms when was fine.
It's okay.
It's not,
that place was the best at Mandalay.
Bay Theater is fucking perfect and it's like 1800 or so people and it's a,
it's fucking packed in there and we did it a few months ago and we're going to
do anything perfectly.
The way to set up theater show for comedy solution.
I think we went through a little bit of a hissy fit today.
Had a little bit of a little bit of a cat fight or you guys can all watch it
too.
It's not a shared number.
23 on desktop or not.
Not as shown him.
It's one of those
are his podcasts is the skeptic tank.
It's on the desk squad.
Yeah.
Naughty though.
There's a bunch of other ones that are really good.
They're the naughty show.
And Tom's Tom and his wife have a your mom's house.
Yeah.
So check that out.
It's a desk quad on iTunes and we'll be back again tomorrow.
Same Bat time.
Same Bat channel with Dunkin motherfucking Trussell.
It's a full desk quad week.
Are you guys going to kiss and make up?
That's why I never even brought it up to him
this week.
And uh,
yeah,
comedy store in La Jolla Friday and Saturday night.
Who you with?
Uh,
sleep.
Some want to go another and just nice,
nice,
excellent combination.
And that comedy store,
if you've never been there.
And commissioning in La Jolla is the shit,
but a jump on it pitches cause it's gonna sell out quick.
It's a,
it's a place is packed all the time.
All right,
that's it.
We'll see you guys tomorrow with Dunkin mothers.
Oh,
fresh light and thanks to the flashlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link for the flashlight in the
corner and enter in the code name Rogan,
you will get 15% off gene number one sex toy for men.
Shoot your loads at that discount.
Do you want one of those?
You sure?
Yeah.
And you'll use it every day until you bleed to death.
It's the cleaning it.
It's,
I don't think that's a good idea to have around on my place.
It's easy.
Okay.
Goodnight.
I love you guys.